This is Jocko podcast number
one 66 with Echo Charles and me,
Jocko Willink.
Good Evening Echo.
Good evening and we are rolling straight
into part three podcast number three of
the psychology for the fighting man.
What you should know
about yourself and others.
So if you haven't listened
to the previous two podcasts,
there are about the same book and there's
so much information that we split it
up because it was going long.
And this part,
these couple of sections here are really
what I was originally going to cover,
but then I figured I'd cover it all.
And next thing you know this turned
into three podcasts series tool and
this section is called the
soldier's personal adjustment.
And here we go back to the book.
In a demo in a democratic civilian army,
millions of men are suddenly abruptly
thrown into a new way of life.
It is in many ways a tough life.
Men used to going their own ways,
choosing their own jobs,
associates neckties times for going to
bed now have to follow military orders
about all these things men accustomed
to a comfortable litter of belongings
around them. Find the bear neatness of
police barracks, hard to get used to.
Those used to steam heat,
warm shower baths and breakfast.
Eggs cooked just three and a half minutes
at home may be pretty uncomfortable
when they have to put up with a bed on
the ground and cold water for shaves.
There is moreover no privacy in the army.
If a man over sleeps and is
corporal dumps him out of his bunk,
the whole company knows about it.
If he looks at his girls photograph a lot,
they know that to the business of living
in a goldfish bowl and having to take
razzing of from his fellow soldiers is
about the hardest thing for a sensitive
recruit to get used to.
That's a fact. So here we go.
These are all just welcome to
the military. You're going to,
you're not going to get to
eat what you want to eat.
You're not going to get to
sleep when you want to sleep.
keep what you want to keep.
Think about those a personal freedoms and
everybody cherishes. They're all gone.
Even your privacy when you get to,
when I went to Navy boot camp,
you go in the bathrooms, there's
just stalls. There's no, I'm sorry.
There's just toilets.
There's no stalls.
You just sit down next to everyone else
and do your business through privacy is
gone.
Yeah.
Not every man of course meets hardships
for the first time when he goes to the
army. Some of known hunger
and cold and hard work,
some never saw flushed toilet or a
shower bath before they got to camp.
Some never had a good square meal.
Well cooked for them.
The army is providing luxuries.
That's true too.
Not Probably.
It's definitely not as true
now as it was in 1942 yeah,
because in 1942 some people were still
living out in the Bush here in America
and there's a lot less people still
living in the bush and America now.
They're still out there though,
but farmer lawyer, banker section,
hand college man or man
of little schooling,
they all must adjust themselves
to an entirely new way of living.
All must learn new habits.
Young men may find it easier to make the
adjustment than older men because they
are ordinarily a little more flexible
with habits. A little less fixed.
That's for sure.
If you think you're going to
join the military at some point,
join when you're as young as possible.
No attachments and I was so
okay.
Just dumb, I guess for lack of a better
word, I just didn't care about anything.
When I came in were like, uh,
we're going to shave your head.
We're going to take all your civilian
stuff. I'm like, whatever, take it away.
I don't care.
But most men can fit themselves into
the new life and work without too much
friction.
Those who do not,
those who do it most easily are the
ones who accept the new life at wants.
Throw off civilian habits with
civilian clothes and put themselves
wholeheartedly into becoming soldiers.
One of the hardest adjustments come
with a loss of contact with family and
friends.
The soldier who misses friends at home
is slow about making new friends at camp.
Okay,
so there you go. If you are homesick,
what you should do is make new friends.
The army is liberal with furloughs as
war permits from such homesick men when
they first go into the service,
but the real remedy is not in hurry trips
home or long distance telephone calls.
It is in building up of new interests
and new ties in and around the camp.
Yeah. When I left home, I left home,
I was gone and just that was that.
One of the fears that many men have to
overcome or adjust to when they first go
into the army is the feeling that
they may lose their identity,
their freedom of individual expression
from revel, Lita taps. There is little,
if any opportunity for the new recruit
to do anything he's not told to do
whether he wants to or not.
He must get up at the sound of the Bugle,
put on the prescribed uniform march when
he has commanded stand at attention,
when he has ordered and do so even
when with a mosquito biting him.
No longer does he eat when he's hungry
or go to sleep when he is tired.
All conduct seems to
be according to order.
Is this really a fight for freedom
and democracy? Of course it is,
but conformity and discipline
are necessary for the
efficient operation of an
army.
And I will say this,
it's only that strict during boot camp.
I mean for the most part during boot camp,
that's when you really are,
every movement that you make is based
on what you're being told to do once you
get into the fleet or out into the,
uh, into a battalion somewhere.
It's definitely, it's not easier, but
you do have more individual freedom.
So you,
some people want to talk to a
kid that's 16 and they are west.
They're worried about,
well you know,
I really like to whatever I like to surf
and I don't want to give up surfing.
You'll have time to surf if you're
stationed somewhere, you know,
joined the coast guard cause they're
always stationed near the water. You know,
there's an idea.
Next a soldiers worries.
There is first the fear of death.
It is best met by accepting
the possibility of death
as a natural part of the
job. And by being careful not to
lose a sense of proportion about it.
Again,
it's weird for me to read this book cause
that's if you had asked me that before
I read this book and that's what I would
have told you you have to do is be like,
yeah, there's a chance I'm going to
die and if you're scared of that,
you should try and get over it.
And I think the sense of proportion
that's saying like, listen, okay,
the world's not going to end if I die.
No soldier is so important that he
isn't justified in thinking the enemy is
aiming every, oh, that's
what they're talking about.
This is that the sense of proportion is
no soldiers and so important that he's
justified in thinking that the enemy is
aiming every bullet bomb and shell at
him.
Besides there are great many men in the
army and only a small proportion get hit
in battle and the greater part of those
who get hit will live and get well
earned relief from the strain of combat.
After that,
there may be a purple heart
decoration and some glory.
This is when we're starting to lean
a little bit towards propaganda.
They were like, listen, you're probably
not going to die. Which that is true.
And the,
the amount of people that are in the
military can be compared to the amount of
people that go into combat compared to
the people that actually make contact
with the enemy compared to the
people that actually get hit.
It's a very small percentage
and if you do get hit,
guess what? You got some glory and
a purple heart coming your way.
Don't worry about it. Yeah, like I said,
this sometimes is leaning a little bit
towards propaganda in a positive and
truthful way,
but you got to,
you got to take it with a grain of salt.
As they say back to the book,
and soldiers who have been through the
worst of warfare are inclined to say that
only a fool wants to live forever.
They usually add the warning,
but if you must die,
make your death count for something.
Don't throw your life away
by taking needless chances.
So that's the old again, uh, some,
some propaganda for you there. Hey listen
man. Only a fool wants to live forever.
Let's go get some, and like I
said, there is some truth to that.
Back to the book.
Sensitive men may also worry or feel
guilty over killing enemy soldiers,
other men in action,
unless they understand this,
worry in face it squarely they may head
into trouble because killing is the main
job of a combat soldier,
okay?
This is something people tend
to forget from time to time,
okay?
The job of a soldier is to kill people,
From the earliest childhood,
American boys are taught that it is wrong.
The greatest wrong to kill.
This principle is learned so early that
it becomes part of them. As boys grow up,
they forget most of what happened
in infancy and early childhood.
Few people in fact can remember much of
what happened in their first three years.
Yet they retained within themselves.
The attitudes formed during
the their earliest years.
They don't remember ever learning them.
It seems as if they always felt that way.
If a man did not learn that it was
wrong to kill until he was grown,
he would learn it then with it,
with his mind,
and he would be easy to lay aside that
rule when war or emergency makes it
necessary for him to kill.
Okay.
But the don'ts learned in
earliest childhood become
the voice of the conscience
in the adult. They seem to be
absorbed rather than learned.
And even though his mind tells a grown
man that the execution of criminals is
justified, his emotions may rebel.
Then if duty forces him to kill,
he may go ahead and do it,
but afterwards he'll feel a vague,
uneasiness and anxiety.
His conscience won't rest.
Some men strictly brought up, may even
get sick at the sick, at the stomach,
at the site of a limp, pathetic
body of a rabbit that has been shot.
The Cure for the exam anxiety that
results from this kind of conflict between
conscience and reason is to understand it.
Once a man realizes that the feeling is
natural in men brought up as an average
American to respect human life,
this particular worry
won't haunt him so much.
He may have a few bad dreams, but that
won't interfere with doing the job ahead.
Disagreeable though it may be.
Again,
this is one where we're trying
to let people know that,
hey,
what you feel when you feel all like,
I don't feel like I want to go kill
people. That's okay, we get it.
Here's why you feel that way.
You feel that way because you've been
told that since you were a little kid,
but you have to bring your reason into
the problem and logically calculate that
it's okay to kill people.
Tough. This is, this is,
this is trying to tell a generation of
American kids that they're going to go
and fight and kill the enemy.
That's what this is doing.
Okay?
And even letting them know like, listen,
you may have a few bad dreams, right?
And that is probably one of the most
minor ways of explaining the fact that you
are going to have freaking
nightmares, cold sweats. And they're,
they're downplaying that,
but they're letting them know that
that's what's going to happen.
So this is,
this is definitely a book
called the psychology
psychology for the fighting man,
and they're trying to use some psychology
here to get the guys in the right
mindset where they can kill
next to the healthy
mind to be at his best.
A soldier must keep his mind
fit as well as his body.
He must be mentally alert and
accurately aware of his surroundings.
He must shoulder responsibility willingly
and except the dictates of superior
officers without resentment.
That's interesting. They used the
word resentment, not without question,
but without resentment.
He must be able to get along with other
men without undue friction and with
mutual pleasure. That's
important. Undue friction.
There's going to be friction.
You're working with other human beings.
All other human beings are crazy.
The marks of a man with healthy mind or
personality are, and that's one thing.
This book continues to do well
as it makes these little lists.
So here's the marks of a man with
a healthy mind or personality. One,
he uses his abilities with
enthusiasm and satisfaction,
although not always with happiness
or full contentment. Okay, so, Eh,
you know,
I might not be totally into this,
but I'm going to get it done
the best possible way to,
he wants to do something worthwhile
to pull his load and not be carried by
others.
It's interesting how a lot of this stuff
is in full alignment with some Jordan
Peterson activities. Someone's
Jordan Peterson statements, right?
Shoulder responsibility willingly.
I think that's a,
I think maybe Jordan read this book.
It is a psychology book and he says
maybe he read this book and started
snatching good material from it.
We're on to you JP.
Uh, but yeah, and even this thing,
man wants to do something worthwhile.
Jordan Peterson talks
about that all the time.
He gets along with other persons including
his superiors and those with whom he
has a difference of opinion.
Very important.
How often is it we see people that
I don't agree with your opinion,
therefore I don't like you and I
can't get along with you. So lame,
so lame.
I actually welcome people that have
differing opinions than me because maybe
they can teach me something.
Maybe I can learn something from their
viewpoint for when he is disappointed or
meets with deprivation or strain.
He faces the situation with constructive
ideas and a fighting spirit,
not with fear, rage,
hopelessness or suspicion.
So then he does not
suffer from in debt,
indigestion, headache or pain,
which though not all at all,
voluntary may be produced
by mental troubles.
So that's how you meet like
problems with a good attitude,
not with fear,
rage and hopelessness.
Five he perseveres in the effort to solve
a problem or complete a task in spite
of the difficulty and disappointment.
Check perseverance.
Six he likes to give as well as take
check.
You ever known those kinds of people
that when they say that they can give but
they can't take? Yes. Yeah. Those
people are fun to hang around.
They never recognize it either. Yeah.
And then if you call someone on it,
like of course it's a denial,
denial, denial in a defensive way,
which is exactly what you're
talking about cause you, you,
you are proving my point right now.
Continuing on some break down mentally
because they are just not fitted for army
life. They never should have
been inducted in the first place.
Physicians at Induction Centers Watch
carefully for the signs of beginning
mental illness.
But nevertheless,
some slip by and actually go through a
pretty good chunk explaining that just
you're not gonna catch every person,
that
that has a possibility of having some
kind of a mental illness of some of them
are going to end up and you've
got to be ready to deal with them.
And those are the people that he,
they say or four doomed to
develop a mental illness.
But then there's people beyond them.
And here we go.
In addition to those men who seem for
doomed to develop a mental illness,
there are other men who break in
the army under battle conditions.
These are real battle casualties just
as much as if they had lost a leg.
So this is interesting because we hear
all these people talking about PTSD and
whatnot as if it's new and
as if it was unrecognized.
This book is written in 1942
and they're saying, hey,
somebody that suffers that kind of
a stress under battle conditions.
That's a casualty.
Just like losing the leg.
So there you go.
Yeah,
and that's the part that's
kind of well themes anyway,
new is that it's just as traumatic as
the physical damage and like you said,
it seems new, right? It seems
new, but this is World War II
and we just don't, we always have to learn
the same lessons over and over again.
Why is that?
Why do we have to learn the same
lessons over and over and over again?
It's a horrible reality.
Back to the book.
A man in battle may receive a blow on
the head that will cause injury to the
brain that is serious,
particularly if he is a leader responsible
for the direction and safety of his
men.
This is an interesting point.
Since the brain itself
has no sense organs,
a man does not feel when his brain is
injured and may think he is not been badly
hurt.
This is how we end up with guys with Tbi,
with traumatic brain injuries cause they
don't, your brain gets rocked around,
but it doesn't, it's not like a bruise.
It's not, it's not aching. I mean,
he'd get a little bit of a headache once
you want you to experience a big boss
like the next day,
and I wonder why I got a little headache.
There's a reason for that,
but even what seems like a slight
wound in the head must be looked after
carefully. Usually the wounded
man should be relieved from duty.
If even a small part of his brain is
hurt or his head is received a hard blow,
which does not even crack the skull,
nevertheless,
he's likely to be confused or to
act in a peculiar way in battle.
So I think it's funny,
it looked,
you got to blow that didn't even crack
your skull. They're like, that's their,
that's their assessment.
It's, it can't be that bad.
It didn't even crack your skull.
A even a guy that didn't crack his skull
needs to get checked out and needs a
little break
back to the book.
A direct blow on the head is not the
only way a man's brain can be injured.
The blast of a shell nearby can cause harm
to the brain. Modern helmets, however,
protect the soldiers that years in his
brain very well. That's kind of rubbish.
The uh,
how the helmet protects your ears and
our helmets obviously or even more modern
than the World War II.
Uh,
steel helmet that there were at
least ours are made of Kevlar. No,
that's not going to protect your ears.
What we do have the protectors
know is we were a lot of,
a lot of people wear headphones for
your radio and they have noise canceling
headphones so that that does protect your
ears. Is it the kind that like go over,
you go over your ears and then there
are ones that go inside your ears too
depending on what you like.
But yeah,
most of most people are wearing noise
cancelling headphones that go over both of
yours and they pick up noise
from the outside and they,
they uh, mute down. Yeah,
really loud noises. Now
one thing that's key,
when you're wearing a headphones,
those headphones on both ears,
you lose.
There's something that you lose.
There's a couple of things that you lose.
You lose the ability to tell distance
how far away something is and where it's
coming from and you lose the ability
to tell where it's coming from.
So if you see pictures of
like me of life of Stoner,
most of the time we have one
year on in one ear off and,
and sometimes people would ask,
people see a picture of like,
what don't you have your headphones on,
here's why you want to be able to hear
direction that someone's yelling for you
and you want to be able to tell somewhat
what the distances and those things are
just gone. Then you have the
noise canceling headphones on,
noise canceling, kind of go in your ears.
There's donuts. There are interesting.
Yeah. The ones, the ones that I
have for shooting do that, you know,
it has a little volume thing
and, and also I don't, obviously,
I don't know exactly how they made
them to work, but the, it's like one,
a gunshot goes off,
it actually mutes everything.
So if I'm talking to you and you know,
a gunshot goes off like that for that
instant use, you go off to, you know,
yeah. And the deal, it is true. You
don't know where it's coming from.
So he could be over here literally on
the opposite side. You know, it's crazy.
Yeah.
So for guys that are in the military or
in some kind of law enforcement where
you're, where you're wearing
those headsets, just be advised.
And I wouldn't go to the point where
I'd cut that other headphone off.
I would keep it, I just push it behind
my ear and wear it that way all the time.
And that way if I needed to,
I could put both headphones
on because you can also run,
and this is another thing
that's a challenge in a
leadership position as you can
run two different radio
frequencies, one into each ear. Uh,
and so when that's going on,
then you've got two voices coming in at
the same time talking about different
things. And it takes a little bit
of practice to get used to that.
And actually it's something that they say
women are better at than men. Yes sir.
They ran a test. Have
you read that? Yes. Yeah.
I read some research about it,
but women can listen to two conversations
easier than men can listen to two
conversations. But can they draw a bicycle
while we've been through this before?
It's risky.
That's a risky conversation.
The same study that or it wasn't the
same study? It was a presentation.
It was like a video with the article.
It was the same one that said about the
drawing the bike thing as the carry on
tooth conversations or
multitask in certain ways where
it requires concentration.
All this stuff. Yes they are.
Yeah. That's interesting.
That's why like my wife can literally
be on the phone and like watch a TV show
that you have to follow.
You don't like do that kind of stuff.
And I'm like the hot breath,
you can't watch this show.
You can be like shopping for
curtains at the same time.
You know like there
were watching the show,
are we shopping for Kirk dance kind
of thing. But they can do that.
The so they have a little
advanced skill there.
So the modern helmets,
they don't practice.
They don't protect your head from shell
blast at all. Even our helmets today,
they don't. Going back to
the book, besides these
direct injuries to the brain,
men in battle can suffer
shocks to the mind every month.
Every man has his limit
mentally as well as physically.
There are strains which no man,
however tough minded minded Ken ender,
modern battle has pushed closer and
closer to these final limits of man's
endurance, grueling
hardships, great fatigue,
prolonged loss of sleep,
blistering heat, intense cold,
high altitudes,
great pressures below the sea.
These are all conditions that put a
dangerous strain on the mind as well as
body.
When a man goes through these things and
then in addition suffered the strain of
seeing his friends killed, of being
in constant peril of his own life,
of dealing out death with his own hands.
There may come a time when the
strongest man's mind will sicken
such a sufferer from war
shock is not a weakling.
He is not a coward.
He is a battle casualty.
If given psychiatric first aid promptly,
he will probably recover to take his
place again in the battle unit if
neglected,
however,
he may become permanently ill or may
even seek relief of his mental wounds in
death.
So again,
this is 1942 and we still hear
information about this nowadays.
Like it's a revelation and it's not.
And you know,
people trying to seek relief
by committing suicide.
That's what they're saying here.
Seek relief from mental wounds in death.
What does that,
that suicide and also,
and I think to me it's always
dick winters that always, uh,
I always get reminded that he's
the guy that would say, look,
if you've got a guy that's getting close,
you pull them off the battle line and
you let them recover and he'll be fine.
If you don't pull them off the
battle line, he's gonna break.
He's going to be no good. The red,
it's the engine, it's the engine,
the car engine running in the red.
The car engine is running in the red.
You need to get it to a service
station and get that thing serviced,
give it a little breather.
And then it'll be fine.
If you get an engine running in
the red and you keep running it,
guess what's going to happen?
You're gonna blow off the engine,
it's going to be done.
It's going to be ruined.
Yeah. So it's kind of like when
you kind of go down that path,
when you think about it, you know, people
who commit suicide just in general,
you know, it kind of is like
kind of got to think about that.
Like they were probably in one way or
another injured right in their brain,
whether it be, you know, for one,
you know, by one way or another.
I think you just, you can't
just, when you say injured,
we're not just talking
about physical injury,
we're talking about whatever stress,
massive amount of stress deaf all
seeing all this May, I'm in chaos.
Yes. So yeah, they have seen,
you got to assume that someone that gets
there in these cases has seen something
that's so bad or suffered
through something that's so
bad that they seek relief
from these mental stresses in death.
Yeah. So even like a, like a
nonmilitary person where you know,
like it's common for people to be
like, oh, he took the easy way out,
the coward kind of thing, right.
He committed suicide kind of thing.
But if you do really hundred
percent regarded as an injury,
just like your arm or your leg or
something like that, it's kind of like it,
it seems like a little bit
more understandable almost
rather than calling them
a coward outright. Yeah.
I'm, I'm not, I'm not sure
about that. I think that,
I think that the most important thing
is to recognize that if someone hurts
their arm and they keep going on it,
their arm is not going to get better.
Right. If someone breaks their
leg and they keep running on it,
their leg is not going to get better.
And if someone's got a,
got some massive amount of stress
that causes a mental injury,
physical, mental injury or mental
psychological, mental injury,
either one of those.
If they don't take a break and
get some help and get some relief,
then it's going to not work. It's
going to break completely. Yeah.
And then they get to a point where this
is what we talk about when we talk about
being in a cloud and
everywhere you look around,
there's nothing but cloud and you think
you're stuck in this storm and there's
no way out. That's where
you end up. And you know, I,
I think Peter Tia posted an article about
a young woman who killed herself and I
wrote something in
response on social media,
something like,
okay,
that's horrible to see.
Especially I think,
I think I wrote something along the
lines of, hey, that's horrible to see,
especially with so many people that
are fighting to live. You know,
you think about people that
have cancer or whatever.
And someone wrote back to me,
okay,
you don't understand mental illness. You
know, you don't understand depression.
And like, I responded back and I said,
and then he kind of said, you know,
it's not like that. And I
said, you're right. I don't,
like, I don't under, I don't,
I'm not a psychologist.
I don't fully understand what
it's like to have this going on.
And it's the same thing when we,
Chris Cornell from Soundgarden killed
himself and I happened to be on Joe
Rogan's podcast the next day
and we started off the podcast.
We were talking about it.
And you know,
it's the same thing because
what Joe Rogan and I are saying,
and we're not psychologists, we're saying
it's got to be hard to dig out of that,
you know, go, go swing a kettle
bell, go do something active,
which to somebody that's
got massive depression that
just sounds idiotic, but to,
to Joe Rogan and I really get a lot of
satisfaction out of swinging kettle bells
and doing Jujitsu. It's like, that
sounds like a decent idea. Right?
It sounds like relief. Yeah. And so, Hey,
I, that's, you know, of course you, yeah,
I should I caveat that statement
with, hey man, I'm not a psychologist.
I don't really know when I'd feel like I,
when I feel like there's
darkness in the world,
I really liked to do something physical.
Tim Ferriss said the same thing.
Get out of your mind, get into your
body like the, okay, so the, the,
you have those conversations.
And you think,
this is what I think, I can't
change what I think, you know,
why this is what I think someone could
change my mind if someone could educate
me. Sure. But I'm just making a statement.
Hey man, that's horrible to see.
Yeah.
It's horrible to see.
Especially when there's people that have
cancer or whatever and they're fighting
as hard as they can to stay alive and
someone else that doesn't have any
diseases decides, you know what,
I'm going to take my own life.
I'm going to kill myself. That's horrible
to see that. That's my statement. Yeah.
And someone you don't understand
this. And I'm like, no, I don't.
That's part of my point is no,
I don't understand this.
And so I,
I will say this,
I've seen how fragile the mind can be.
Yeah.
And really why should,
I should rephrase that.
How fragile the mind is because I've
seen people that seem to be going down a
good path in,
in all of a sudden out of nowhere
that path is, they're gone. And,
and that's like shocking.
So one thing I guess I,
the part that I understand is that I don't
understand it and it's hard for me to
relate to that and it's hard for
me to understand and say, wow,
I could have seen that common.
No,
actually I couldn't seem
that common at all at all.
So the interest,
the most interesting thing about this
to me is this book is from 1942 and it's
talking about the same things that were
apparently still discovering right now
like that sometimes you need a break
from combat like that when you come home
you might be a little bit,
you might have some nightmares
like that.
If you break mentally,
it doesn't mean that you're a weak link.
And Band of brothers
does a great job of that.
The one character who's a total bad
ass through and all of a sudden he just
can't take anymore. And
they go, okay, no problem.
And Dick winters talks
about it and he says, yeah,
we no one lost any respect for that guy.
The guy took his risks,
he did a great job,
and then he couldn't do it anymore.
And David Hackworth describes it as,
hey,
you people have a cop and the cop
gets filled up and we'd filled up.
It's filled up.
You can't put any more in there.
He can't put any more combat in there.
And it's not,
some people have a bigger cup than other
people. It's no disrespect. It's not,
it's not a negative statement,
it's just that's the way it is.
So if someone gets in
these bad situations,
what in my opinion you
have to do is take a break,
get someone to help get
someone to talk to about it,
that can help you find
your way out of the store.
But that's what I realized from,
from the times we've had.
Speaking of of Jordan Peterson,
the Times that we,
for the first time we had him on here,
I had never really spent any time
thinking about psychology as an actual
possible thing in the world.
You know what I mean?
Just kind of seemed like Voodoo
to me. Right. It's, yeah. Yeah.
And then when he was talking through
some of the psychological protocols that
they use to come over particular to
overcome particular psychological issues,
I was like, oh, okay. So this
basically is like a car mechanic,
right? You come in with and you've
got this problem with your car, cool.
This is what we're gonna do to
fix that problem with your car.
And so there's a certain amount of
psychology that was revealed to me from
Jordan as like, oh yeah, this
is when you have this situation,
this is what you do to heal it. And so
it's important. I, that was kind of a,
that was, uh, that was a revelation to me.
Not like a revelation that changed
my world, but it was, for me,
psychology was just always kind of Voodoo.
That's what it seemed like to me.
Looking at it from the outside. And I'm
an ignorant person, right? Seriously,
I'm an, I'm kind of an ignorant
person. I, I graduated high school,
I grew up in the middle,
a, grew up in the military.
I spent all my time around a bunch
of other knuckleheads like me.
It's like you're,
you're not talking this vast with this
vast experience of all these different
data points of the world. It's like, no,
I'm just a guy who never really dealt
with psychology before. So for me,
I just looked at, oh, it's just
some weird people laying on a couch.
You know what I learned from the movies?
And so I didn't see the benefit of,
Hey, oh, they actually have
identifiable problems that they can see.
And then they have
protocols to overcome those.
So if someone is out there and
they're caught in this storm,
whatever that storm may be,
if you go to one of these brain mechanics,
if they would've called it brain mechanic,
I would have understood it.
Go to a brain mechanical,
they're called a psychologist to
a brain mechanic and say, hey,
this is the problem that I'm having
right now. Can you give me a tuneup?
And the brains, the brain mechanic
will say, Yep, here's the protocol.
I want you to do this.
I want you to write down this.
I want you to talk about this. I
want, and that's what they do. Yeah.
Mental Danger Signals back to the book.
Mental first aid is just as important
as physical first aid for preventing
casualties and losses to the service.
If a 1942 if a man can be relieved of
duty for a time given a rest when he needs
it urgently,
he can usually be counted upon to come
back to the combat presently with fresh
zest and vigor.
If however,
he's allowed to go on past his
mental breaking point without let up.
If he is permitted to wait
until he collapses or until
the urgency of his needs
makes him go on sick call voluntarily,
the chances are much smaller for his rapid
recovery checkout world war one shell
shock and that's what you end up with.
Guys that are mentally destroyed by
the horror that they see and the on
remitting nonstop presence of this horror
you have to give guys breaks if they
need it.
Next,
the first thing to look for is anything
that makes a man stand out in an awkward
way from the others in his unit.
Anything that makes him look odd
to the other men marks him as not.
Does he stay by himself too much?
Does he go for long
periods without speaking?
Is he known to other men
as having strange ideas?
Does he find conditions intolerable
than other men get along under?
All right. Is He a problem in the
outfit? Refusing certain foods,
wetting the bed following
strange or peculiar practices?
Does the sergeant regardless,
regardless peculiar.
Another thing to look for is any sudden
change in the soldier's own personality.
If he is a man who has been in the
outfit for a while, it's easy to,
it's easy to note a complete reversal of
habits or attitudes when the ordinarily
cheerful man becomes moody and depressed.
When the quiet orderly soldier becomes
boisterous and noisy and a disciplinary
problem. When the neat well groomed
man becomes dirty and disheveled,
let's his shoes going shined his
uniform on button his hair and combed.
When the dependable mangoes a
wall and starts drinking hard,
these are signs to look for for mental
trouble. They should be looked into.
The guard house may not be any help at
all. Sometimes it makes things even worse.
It's worse. So just because someone starts
getting in trouble, hey, you know what?
We do film in the brig as not going
to make things any better. In fact,
it could make things worse.
Back to the book when a man
has been through a particularly
trying experience in
combat without relief for a long period
under steady bombing or gunfire without
protection cutoff from other
troops are lost at sea.
More cute signs of war nerves may show up.
All men should know that these signs
are the natural result of fear and war
strain. They do not mean
that a man has gone insane,
but they do mean that he needs care.
Rest,
medical attention and mental first aid
and here's some signs of that.
Here's some signs of severe stress,
inability to sleep,
terrible nightmares in which the
battle is repeated over and over,
inability to eat, buzzing or humming in
his ears, shakiness, general weakness,
weakness in certain parts of his body
as the knees or the rest of dizziness.
Peculiar feelings in the heart,
fluttering, pounding, skipping a beat,
difficult breathing,
relentless combined,
but let restlessness combined with a
feeling of being penned in an overwhelming
desire to push people
and walls out of the way.
Rest is the principal cure for
these indications of Warner's
rest and the care of a medical man
who understands such cases and an
understanding on the part of the
soldier of what is wrong with him.
These feelings are natural enough for
anyone who's gone through the difficult
conditions of combat,
but they are very frightening to a
man who does not expect them even more
distressing than the shells or
bombs or torpedoes themselves.
This is when it's important to
understand what's happening.
If you don't know why you're shaking,
if you don't know why
you can't sleep at night,
if you don't know why you can't eat,
why you feel weak,
like there's why there's
ringing in your ears.
If you don't understand why
those things are happening, you,
it's going to be worst for you.
It's just unexpected.
It's unknown and we're
afraid of the unknown.
Officers who understand these matters
can do a great deal to relieve the men's
fears of war nerves and to prevent them
by their own calm recognition of the
fact of nerves and their costs. So
hey, officer's like, Hey man, look,
you just got you.
You've been out here a little too long.
We're going give you a little breather.
How the mind protects itself.
The body has defense mechanisms,
so has the mind to touch a piece of hot
metal and instantly you have withdrawn
your hand before you
know what you are doing.
If something flies towards your face,
you shut your eyes without stopping
to decide how to close them.
These are natural means
for self protection.
When the mind is attacked by
unpleasant ideas, dangerous fears.
It too has a way of withdrawing rough,
turning away and shutting
out what cannot be endured.
When you see a man of ordinary co good
common sense become strangely blind to
facts.
Refuse to believe that his lost brother
has really been killed or refuse to see
that he's he himself is to
blame for a disastrous failure.
That man's mind is automatically
protecting itself from
a truth so bitter that
he can't take it
little bit delusional.
It might be dangerous even where
it possible to convince them,
convince a man of the actual facts
he might if compelled to face them,
commit suicide.
That has happened more than once
and obstinate refusal to accept the truth
on the part of a man of ordinary good
judgment is a danger signal just as a
fever of 103 degrees is a signal of a
serious physical danger.
Don't try to argue with such a man.
He should be given a rest or a
furlough from the duty and the strain.
It is apparent that the mind is
hard hit when he is fit again,
he will be able to see clearly once more,
he will rate himself and go back to
normal just as the fever patient patient
does when its temperature goes back down,
but it is only when the mind's natural
protective mechanism are used to an
excessive or unreasonable
extent that they, that they,
that they point to a
sick or exhausted mine.
Every normal man uses them daily.
To some extent.
This is the way they work and it's goes
through a bunch of things that we all do
on a daily basis.
Normal people to deal with things.
One,
passing the buck.
You see this every day when a
man fails or or his humiliated,
he can shrug it off or freely admit his.
It is his own fault.
If the failure is trivial,
I did not mean much to him or
if he has strong character.
If the failure is a
great personal tragedy,
all but the man of an extraordinary
strength of character,
we'll try to put the blame
on someone or someone else,
someone or some thing else.
The man who thus fails,
we'll seize upon any plausible excuse.
He blames the weather,
the man who gave him wrong advice
or the man who got in his way.
Sometimes he may even imagine a plot
against himself and persuade him that
everybody is down on him humiliation and
defeat our hard to bear instinctively.
Every man wants to try it
once to get out from under.
When blame hangs over him.
Habits of good sportsmanship
usually prevent him from doing so,
but still in his own mind or
among friends, he will say,
but it wasn't my fault.
That's an amazing section,
obviously directly related to
the idea of extreme ownership.
The fact that it's only a
man of extraordinary strength
of character who will
take the blame. That's the only, that's
the only person everyone else is going to.
I think what's important about this is
to recognize that we all subconsciously
know this.
So when you screw something
up and you go, well, you know,
we didn't get the supplies we were
supposed to get and that's why we failed.
Everybody knows that.
That's a little character flaw.
You got right there to shine through.
That's what's going on, right?
It's a little character flaw
and you hear it all the time.
It's so obvious to everyone
when you're making an excuse.
Well, it, no one
believes your excuse. You don't
want, it leaves your excuse.
Even if everyone's making an
excuse. Yeah, it doesn't matter.
It's still the subconscious. Everyone
let, let's say me, you, I dunno.
Lafe there's a bunch of people in a
room and we're all making excuses.
It almost seems like each
individual guy would be like,
oh, they're making excuses. Meanwhile,
like they're not thinking, oh,
I'm making it uses too. You know?
It's a scary thing. And what's cool is
as soon as someone goes, hey, you know
what? This is actually my fault. Yeah.
Other people go,
Oh man,
I need to say that too, cause I
screwed some stuff up. Yeah, it's all,
it's kind of like you ever been in like
a big meeting and it kind of goes off
the rails a little bit.
You have. Okay, good. Wait,
have you ever been in a big meeting?
What was your big meeting with like
your wife and your tickets? Believe me,
that's a huge meeting.
The, and then, you know,
let's say it goes off the rails and people
start like essentially raising their
voice. Maybe not yelling, but you
know, and I'll, everyone's talking,
you can't hear what anyone's saying.
Right.
But everyone's voicing their
opinions essentially, just,
just a little bit more passionately.
Right. But you can't hear anybody.
What did anyone say? Right?
You know that happens a lot,
so it's kind of the same concept because
even when you are saying anything,
everyone else is talking. You're
compelled to be like, be quiet, but oh,
what you just do it there. You just
added to the noise with the thing.
Rather than like handling it kind
of consciously and be like, okay,
I'm not going to add to the noise.
I'm going to be quiet.
Yes.
Taking ownership is contagious
and making excuses is contagious.
They're both contagious.
Yeah.
They'll both run ramping wild until you
put a check on them. The good thing,
the good news about that
is taking ownership is the
stronger power. So if you,
if someone in that group starts to take
ownership that that virus will spread
stronger than the excuse making virus.
Okay. The next thing that
people do is the false front.
When a man is worried by the fear,
perhaps only half consciously,
but deep in his heart that he has
serious that he has a serious fault or
weakness,
what does he do?
He puts up a great show of being
just the opposite sort of person.
If the man is stupid or ineffective yet
feels a need to be strong and sure he
will overdo his efforts to impress people.
You will be loud and boisterous and cocky.
The timid person may do foolhardy
stunts seeking to prove his bravery.
The man who is really courageous,
strong and manly.
Seldom knee feels, any need to demonstrate
it. He just takes himself for granted.
So there's a bunch of bed,
obviously we see this all time.
People are insecure about
the way they do something.
They try and give the false
front that they're great at it.
I remember when I was young and I bleached
my hair blonde did a few times by the
way. That's interesting. Yeah.
So it wasn't like super
long and I'm like this,
but it just shirt and us.
I was a girl, he said,
hey you,
you just do that for attention.
Yeah.
And I'm thinking to myself like, well I
don't like, I don't do it for attention.
You know, and then you thought
to yourself more, you know,
it kinda sticks with you.
Like am I doing it for attention?
I'm not realizing it kind of
thing. And some fee, you know,
you go round and round in
your head, you're like, then
why did I do it? You know,
do it, did I like, like
how it specifically looked
because it does stand out.
I knew that from the beginning.
What age is this? Uh,
2020,
20,
21 maybe? Yeah, like 20th.
Okay. [inaudible] 97.
Yeah, 20. See, anyway, so after you
think about it, you're like, yeah,
cause you know,
I liked how it looked at the time and
yeah, I wanted people to sort of look, you
know, it was a, so then what did you do?
Nothing. Do you, didn't you kept I
admitted it to myself. Yeah, I kept it.
And then yeah, there's a lot. Uh,
there's a lot of wrestlers like the
high school wrestlers that do that.
There's whole teams, whole
teams. Everyone's got their
hair bleached blonde. Yeah.
Will it, cause there's a level of
arrogance which with wrestling. Yeah.
Well yeah, like self confidence.
Like, Hey, I'm going to
going to make this happen.
And it's, it's a psychological game,
right? I'm not scared of you. Look at me.
I'm,
I actually bleached blonde,
my hair look at me cause I'm
about to stick you on the mat.
Okay.
So other than semantics,
is there a difference
between the expression I want
attention or I'm doing it
for attention versus I'm doing it to stand
out. I think those are the same thing,
but one kind of sounds more like
kind of superficial kindness.
So you just want attention. Yeah.
No I'm doing to stand out. You know,
I want to stand out.
That's a good thing to stand up.
That's a not a great
argument is what I'm saying.
Being being the,
hey I just want to stand out.
That's the most positive possible way
of saying I just want attention. Yeah,
because what you want.
Yeah.
Cause if you say Elena
stand out cause you can um,
like try to stand out or pursue standing
out as a good thing for a good reason.
You know, like I wanna stand out,
I want my business to stand out.
I don't want my x, Y, z thing
to stand out. So, you know,
so people don't have no sign on it
or whatever. But if you're like,
I want to do it for attention, it just
sounds like I just want the attention,
like if that's what I want,
that's the end goal of the attention.
That's what it feels like when you say it.
Even though there's sort of the
same thing. There are the things,
I was playing soccer when I was a kid
and my dad,
my parents were school teachers.
Yeah. They're not a lot of
money in school teaching and we,
my dad,
I needed a pair of cleats,
so I'm probably eight years old and my
dad goes to the sporting good store,
digs into the the bin of leftovers
second hand whenever any gets.
And the pair of cleats that fit me is
white. It's a pair of white cleats.
Yeah. This is 19 whatever. 78 does.
No one with white cleats. This is
not for, everyone has black lights.
So I go to the soccer
game and like I said,
I think we through white cleats. Cleats.
Yeah, because my dad, they were the cheap,
they went in the bargain bin.
Right.
It wasn't like my dad on the school
teacher's salary was like, hey,
which pair do you want from this rack
over here? No, you're getting the,
the new buck. You know what that is?
No, it's a fake leather, you know,
so you're just getting a fake leather
plastic cleats. They're white, whatever.
But I was out on the
soccer pitch and I think,
I want to say I scored a goal I think,
and as I was running back,
uh,
so like a dad from the other
team said something like,
you know, you think you're the big
star now with those white cleats.
I don't know if he was being nice.
He might've been being nice.
It didn't sound like it to me at the time.
I think that right there was like
the beginning of me thinking,
I don't want to be the guy
that's dying their hair.
A bright blonde at 21 years old.
Yeah.
When you said maybe 21
you're going to be that.
You think you're going to be the big star
now he said something with those white
cleats.
It was something like that.
I can't remember very much from
my childhood that I remember.
Remember when you were playing like the,
this is not some big soccer,
you know they got kids playing soccer now.
They got there looking like a
professional soccer. No, this is,
you remember them things that you
had when you were a little kid.
That yellow shirt that was like elastic
around the bottom and you just put it on
over your other shirt.
So it was like the yellow team versus the
other team who was one of those things.
We're not talking high level, we're not
talking to high level soccer playing.
We're talking yellow jersey,
yellows against the regular kids.
Intermural.
So there I was with the white cleats on
and I remember thinking that guy thinks
that I'm trying to make a spectacle out
of myself. And he didn't say nice goal.
He said,
oh you think you got some Nice cleats?
Were you celebrating all hard or
something or you know, running thing.
I was running back. Yeah.
Yeah. He was hating.
I'm trying to think of when I celebrated
hard cause that's something that,
that's something I remember a couple of
times in my life celebrating hard and
being like, man that was a bad move. And
again, it's probably the same age group,
you know, like yeah, it's weird man.
That's, that's kind of deep though.
Were where that the,
cause it's the opposing team's
debt or somebody on their
feelings. Um, cause yeah,
I wonder right, because there's
two things that he couldn't be,
he was hating regardless and he was
a mad, you know, goal obviously.
But was he like, oh you think you're
the big shot now? Like hating on,
that's what I heard.
You're cool.
Or was he hating like on a
deeper level where he was like,
oh you think you're a big shot?
Oh, but look here kind of thing.
Was he saying that the way I
interpreted it was he was saying,
you think you're special because
you've got those white cleats on.
He didn't know that.
Then we're the only place I got her.
Cause my dad's a notoriously cheap guy.
My Dad,
we could tell stories
about my dad. All, all 10,
15 podcasts worth of penny
pinching come up from the old man.
So you weren't getting these normal
cleats. These are bargain bin cleats.
So that's what we're talking
about. Yes sir. Number three,
taking it out on the dog.
The man who suffered injury and
is not strong enough to hit back.
May literally take it out on the dog or
may go around looking for trouble with
someone else. He can talk back to a
punch in the, in the nose. Yeah, check.
Here's one borrowed virtue.
A more constructive or helpful sort
of mental protection mechanism is this
action of a man who feels
weak or inadequate by himself
and who gains a feeling
of strength and superiority by attaching
themselves to a stronger man or a
strong group.
It was this that sent so many men to
their recruiting stations on the morning
after Pearl Harbor.
As a man alone,
you feel powerless in the
face of threatening dangers
as United States soldier.
You know, you can go anywhere
in the world, avenge wrongs,
and protect your treasured way of life.
So if there's a positive way that we,
we we roll.
Number five is sick call.
When your mind is called upon to
face something you dread terribly,
your body may come,
come promptly to your rescue.
The aviation student who really dreads
to go up for his first solo feeling,
sure he is going to crack up his plane
may develop a convenient but real
headache on that day. He, yeah,
you see that happen, right? And
a little feel good. You speed.
It happened with little kids
to first Jiu Jitsu tournament.
He'd come sick first. Whatever
you know, first basketball game,
I'm feel good. Shut up. You feel fine
moving on the war within the man.
It might be much easier to defeat the
enemy if men could only win in some way.
The conflicts that very often
going go on within themselves.
A man. So this is, this
is where we go dichotomy.
The new level of dichotomy
be digging in right here.
A man so often wants to do two opposite
things at the same time and he wants
desperately to do both.
He wants to dominate other
men and yet be liked by them.
He wants to give vent to his anger,
but he doesn't want to get in hot water.
He wants to gain promotion, but it
doesn't want to do all the hard work.
Above all,
he wants to be a brave and treat true
soldier to keep the soldiers faith,
and yet he wants to live
how to be brave and safe.
That is the greatest psychological
problem for the soldier.
Most of the war neurosis,
mental illness in parentheses,
result from the failure of men to find
any sort of satisfactory way out of that
dilemma.
Every man is equipped with two kinds of
the deep seated desires or instincts.
Often these two conflict, one set has
to do with his relations with other men.
He wants to be one of the gang appreciated
and admired by others and he even
likes to sacrifice himself for the
good of the group to which he belongs,
whether it is his family,
church, army, or nation,
but he also has another set of desires
that cannot ever be entirely denied
desires connected with himself. His
life has comfort, his personal freedom.
No amount of patriotic fervor can wholly
kill or drown out the calls of the more
personal instincts.
Only a few rush to enlist
with no misgivings.
Most for most men,
there is some concern or distress in
making the decision to leave home,
family and job in order to join
the service of the country.
A move to a war theater and an advanced
to close contact with the enemy usually
brings a crisis in the battle within
the soldier as well as in the battle
against the enemy. When a man finds
himself close indeed to death,
that his instinct to self preservation,
one of the most powerful urges every
normal man has makes every fiber of his
being protested against facing the danger.
Yet his comrades,
his officer's his country,
are all counting on him to
do his bit a pretty big bit,
risking his own life.
Yet they are counting on him.
If the personal instincts,
when the struggle, the man,
when contact with the enemy forces is
made, we'll run away or will surrender.
If the social instincts prevail,
then he is the stuff of which all
good soldiers, all heroes are made.
Most men who have traveled the hard path
of army life up to the front lines put
up a good fight once they get
there for a few. So there you go.
You either have guys that go, okay, you
know what? Of course I want to stay alive,
but I'm going to be loyalty to my country,
my army,
my team that I'm with and the guy to my
left and my right. And so guess what?
I'm going forward into the fray.
The other that,
that make the other decision
arc. Well, you know what?
I want to stay alive
so I'm gonna run away.
So there's two distinct types of
behaviors. Most of the time it's, hey,
we're gonna put up the good fight.
Occasionally it's a coward and then
this is the interesting one for a few.
However, this struggle ends
in a stalemate, a compromise.
That is what a war neurosis is.
A compromise of this internal conflict.
If a man goes on being torn
by as conflicting desires,
if he cannot bring himself to go forward
yet is to conscientious to give up,
he will suffer from the type of neurosis
characterized by anxiety he finds he
can no longer concentrate. He becomes
confused. The expression on his face,
his pulse rate and his rapid breathing
betray the fierce battle going on with
him within him.
He himself may not be fully aware of
the cause of this terrible sense of fear
and horror of it seems to hang over him.
Yet he is in a way solving his problem.
He is making himself too
inefficient to continue to fight,
yet giving himself so much suffering
that is conscious cannot accuse him of
taking the easy way out yet even so,
he does not know that
he is doing all this.
His nervous system does it for him.
The man who suffers in any of these ways
is not to be blamed. He's not a coward.
If he were, he would have no
conflict. That's an interesting point,
so if you're just a coward, you just
like, screw it, I'm out of here.
But the guy that freezes up and to
get so nervous he doesn't want to run,
but he doesn't want to go fight.
He can't solve that conflict in his head.
Back to the book. If he were,
he would have no conflict.
He would see to it that he was
not at the front but in a soft,
safe job somewhere at a good distance
in if necessary he would dessert,
but he does not dessert
and still does not fight.
He compromises with a difficult,
unpleasant alternative one
which he does not choose,
but which has nervous system chooses
for him. He cannot control it.
The leader who lectures him balls amount
or punish as him for neglect of duty is
only to increase his trouble.
On the other hand,
coddling such men is a mistake too, so
you can't go to, you got to balance this.
You can't go super hard on them,
but you can't coddle them either.
You need to balance this dichotomy.
What they need is understanding,
help the reinsurer,
reassurance that comes from a firm but
friendly attitude on the part of those
who deal with them.
They need the encouragement of assurance
that such things happen to the best of
men, but that men may get over
such difficulties with aid.
They need to be told that they will
be helped by a good night's sleep,
perhaps drug induced by the
medical officer by a good
meal and by rest and that
then they will be expected to return the
f to the fight and do their duty with
the others.
So that's a pretty interesting way
of looking at it. And I would say,
as I thought about that, think
about how many, how much,
how much nervousness you feel.
If you think about the nervousness is
actually it's an internal war between two
decisions that you could be making,
right? Yeah. What should I do?
Should I buy this new car or save
the money, right? Like, well,
which one should I do? I really want the
car. But I know it should save money.
You get this little internal internal
conflict and that's what the struggle is.
You're not really actually nervous
about buying the new car and you're not
nervous and I'll save money.
Your nerve,
you can't make a decision based on the
two things that you want to make happen.
So we get those little, I think
it's, if you, if you frame things up,
if you're feeling
stressed about something,
if you frame up what is
actually stressing you out,
there's a good chance of what's actually
stressing you out is you're just trying
to figure out which decision to
make. Yeah, yeah. That is true.
And one thing that you can do is you can,
if you play your card,
if your brain plays the game out,
you can be so you can
not make a decision. Oh yeah. Because
hey, you're just not making a decision.
It's like that.
It's crazy how they,
I mean that's the first I've heard anyone
articulate that little bit. Cause Bro,
I'll get that in the most
like stupid mundane things.
So okay.
Bear with me some with some
unloading unloading the dishwasher.
So on this side of my kitchen,
which is like,
it's kind of a longer like kind
of kitchen where, so on this side,
this is where pots go the,
but it's not just positive to pots and
then certain kinds of little these little
soy sauce dishes.
And,
and then on this side it's like silverware
and then there's like plates, right?
So I'm unloading the dishwasher and I'm
trying to be efficient. I'm not rushing,
but I'm trying to be efficient. So
I'm grabbing, I have like, you know,
I get like maybe four
dishes of sorts at a time.
And so,
but I look at what I grabbed
and I get this feeling like,
shoot, where do I go? Do I
go here first? You know, and
put away the pots first that I
have in my hand or doing over here.
Because if I go over here, I can
do that, you know, kind of thing.
And I'm at this little conundrum, but
I'm like, you know what I should do,
and this is all just going on in my head.
It takes maybe like four or five seconds,
but
it seems kind of long.
But I don't want her,
you ain't making videos during their
debate yourself about pots and pans and
glasses and soy sauce dishes.
Who has a soy sauce dish?
Is that an actual thing bro?
It's bad because this is Lee.
I'm not exaggerating.
This literally goes into my head and
it's this micro little almost anxiety.
This is not exact, but it's
like it's there. It's something.
It's not like nothing,
you know? I'm not just like, oh, just
making, taking action. I'm not doing that.
I'm like literally standing there not
doing anything, thinking about this stuff.
So I'm like,
okay,
why have not in a situation where you
have to make actual decisions, boom,
that would be a problem. If this is
any indicator, it will be a problem.
So I'm looking and I'm like, shoot, where
should I go straight to the that I said,
no, you know what I'm gonna do.
I'm gonna put, put this whole site.
Is this the dishes that go on this side?
Because I'm going to put
those back home to grab stuff.
They've all gone that tight.
But wait,
now I've got to take the time to put this
back in, searching and grab other ones.
I'm losing time. That's less efficient
given the point that I'm at right now.
So I'm like, man. And then you know, and
then of course I'll just be like, yeah,
whatever. I'll just kind of
go. But the point is, Brad,
that happens is it literally happens
if it happening happening to you.
Echo Charles with the dishes.
Yeah.
I can imagine that other people feel it
when there's actual decisions to be made.
And just to wrap this whole thing up,
and I don't want to talk about that
anymore ever. But if you were smart,
you would just organize your kitchen so
that everything is located co located.
All things that go from dishwasher
go into this small area.
So think about that one.
Well,
don't think about it for too long because
I don't want you to freaking stress
out anxiety,
but that a lot of those like he that
he puts it in terms of like a two time
kinds of instincts, right? Yeah. What
social and we're social human survival.
Yeah.
It's like a big one is a way to see it.
It's like how you pointed
out to me like the long game,
you know it's like either you're
playing the short game, the long game.
So it's kind of like that.
Like there's like you,
you had the example of
the buying the car thing.
That's the short term versus
long term payoffs situation.
Most things are when you have that
little conundrum, you know, like you,
I'm gonna eat this pot of brown
or at least pan of brownies,
but I want to eat those products because
they're delicious but I don't want to
get, you know, you know, put on
weight or whatever. You know,
it's kind of the same thing I
want both kind of thing. But,
and they most of the time I think anyway,
it sorts itself out to be a short
term versus long term struggle.
And I think the important thing here is
that you can actually take this concept
and apply it to meaningful decisions
that human beings have to make.
Not just soy sauce bowls and brownies.
No Diet is a big one day.
It is. It's not a big one.
When you compare it to storming
the beaches of you. Oh, Jima.
Just saying I agree with that.
Yes sir. And speaking of which,
and this is where this is obviously,
this is part here,
is probably written more
directed at you back to the book.
Men differ greatly in their abilities
to stand up under this internal personal
conflicts.
Most men can come successfully
through terrorizing experiences,
revolting scenes and exposure to it.
Def War is older than history in all
nations and tribes have resorted to it.
So
even the terrorizing experience that you
have. Yeah, with the soy sauce bowls.
Oh, that one's garden. That's rough.
Continuing.
The average soldier has conflicts,
but settles them himself
with no one else the wiser.
So he finds himself free to fight
with his whole strength on him.
The average free soldier victory depends.
Fortunately,
the first contact with the enemy
is the hardest in seasons. Troops,
internal conflict diminishes.
They have faced the worst and no,
it is not intolerable. Even soldiers
who have to retreat or not defeated.
If they have learned to
conquer their own fears,
that's a good one. Even soldiers
who have to retreat or not defeated,
if they have learned to conquer their own
fears, they will advanced another time.
Having once won the fight with the inner
man and having faced the reality of
battle,
finding it,
finding it less terror and
more opportunity for success
than the green recruit
could ever have believed possible.
Yeah.
So now we get to this section
in the book and like I said,
this is the second that I
actually wanted to cover,
but we ended up covering this whole
on over the course of three podcasts.
And this section is called leadership.
You can't boss a brick,
you can't even boss a dog unless the dog
has been trained to obey and has formed
habits of responding to commands.
And before you can boss him,
you must know what commands you will
spawn to the famous seeing eye dogs can do
wonderful things to aid the blind.
But both dog and master must first
go through a period of training.
So there you go.
Okay.
And now we get this off.
40 is not power.
Yeah,
that's an epic statement.
Listen to this.
No amount of legal authority over the
grizzly bears of British Columbia would
enable you to get yourself
obeyed by them out in the woods.
Men can be commanded only after they
have acquired habits of obeying after and
after.
Their leader has learned to give them
commands that make these habits work.
All successful leadership dust depends
on the habits of those who are to be led.
The officer's standing before his men
is limited in the direct exercise of his
authority by what the troops are able
to get through their eyes and ears.
So this is this interesting you're going
to see in this opening section here.
It's really leaning towards that
traditional military id of leadership.
It's like, look, if you're trained
correctly and I give you an order,
you're going to listen.
And so that's,
that's where this thing
kind of starts off with.
And as you probably can figure out,
that's contrary to to what I believe
effective leadership to consist of.
But it's talking about it.
And even though I don't believe that's
the most effective form of leadership.
And a matter of fact, I know it's not
That being said,
it is a form of leadership and it is,
it can be effective. It does work
in many situations where it's like,
look, I'm the boss, I'm the one
that's right. The paychecks,
I'm the one that's got the rank and
when I tell you to do something,
you know you're going to get it done.
And that is a normal sort of baseline,
rudimentary,
okay
form of leadership. So it
does exist. Back to the book,
when a 40 is not obeyed,
the fault may lie in the manner of speech
of the leader or else it may be that
the men are, are in need of basic
training. So it looks so you look,
if people aren't listening to you,
it could be the,
the way that you're talking to them.
And now it starts to,
and the reason I said this is starting
off talking about type of leadership that
I don't really find to be optimum at all.
But you're going to see that it starts
to lead towards the type of leadership
that I do believe to be effective and
they actually believe it to be the most
effective too.
So continue on.
It is often said that a good
leader knows how to handle his men
actually. However, it is not possible
for any leader to handle his men.
Okay?
It is
himself that he handles.
Okay.
Then the men react to his department and
the way in which they react to pens in
term on their habits
of thought and action.
So that's a great statement
of being the leader.
It's it's you don't handle your men,
you handle yourself.
You're the one that you need to handle.
And then if you handle yourself correctly,
the team will then react to the
way that you handle yourself.
So that now we're starting to lean towards
what I believe to be good leadership.
That's leading by example.
Next section. Discipline
in an army.
Much of this training on which leadership
depends is established by discipline.
Discipline is training in the
habits of attention and obedience.
Without such habits, we might have
a crowd or a mob, but not an army.
It is quite possible to lead a mob.
Yet such leadership is uncertain depending
largely on the accidents of personal
appearance and unfortunate
timing in an army. However,
there have been many leaders of many
ranks and they have been interchangeable.
Okay.
If a leader is killed, another must be
ready to take his place and lead men.
So it's talking about discipline and this
is talking about the traditional form
of military discipline. Hey,
there's a rank structure.
You must be obedient and that is not
the optimal type of discipline that I
believe in, which is, hey, we are a
discipline team. We have discipline,
standard operating procedures.
We understand what the mission is,
we understand what the goals are.
We are going to move in that direction
with discipline and the discipline is not
imposed.
Discipline that I impose on my team,
it's disciplined that they impose on
themselves because they realize that it
makes them more effective and more
efficient and more likely to be able to
accomplish the mission
which they believe in.
Now it talks a little bit
about learning obedience.
Okay.
And again, obedience to me
is not something that I'm
looking for for my team.
It's not what I'm looking for.
I'm not looking for obedience.
I'm looking for people that know how to
understand what the goal is and they're
going to move towards the goal.
Hmm.
The first requisite of
command is attention.
So you got to get people to pay
attention to you. That makes sense.
What men do invariably and repeatedly
is finally drilled into them,
becomes for them.
Second Nature,
they learned to perform acts or maneuvers
and response to commands or orders.
Because the commando order has always
been accompanied by the act and the act by
the command. Mere lecturing never
trains men in action. At best,
it makes them learn mere words sequences,
except when the listeners already know
enough about the required action to
perform it. An imagination
learning new, in other words,
requires participation.
You don't learn to swim by taking
a correspondence course. So yes,
you have to drill people.
You have to get it,
make it second nature that that is true.
And we do that in,
we did that in the seal teams.
They do that in the military.
People know what they're gonna do when
they get shot at. They know what the,
from a certain direction,
everyone knows what they're gonna do
and we drill it over and over and over
again until you don't have to think about
it. It's second nature. Unfortunately,
bad habits as well as good can be learned.
If on spoken command,
men do not respond,
then they are learning not to respond.
Whenever they are ordered to
do something they cannot do.
They are learning to
disobey military manuals.
Embody this fact in a rule.
Never give a command that you
do not expect to be obeyed.
Now that's a brilliant statement and I
don't necessarily think it's a brilliant
statement for the same reasons,
but actually pretty close.
If you wait,
if,
if I'm looking at you and
you're working for me and I say,
yeah, you need to get all this stuff move
by by noon today and I know there's no
physical way for you to do it,
I'm wasting it. And, um, um,
I'm diminishing my authority over
you because you're thinking, no,
there's no way I can do that. So now
you're definitely not going to do it.
And the next time I say to get
something done, you've got to,
you've got to already a
preconceived notion that you
don't really have to do it.
So that's a great statement.
If you're in charge,
never give a command that you don't
expect to be obeyed. Don't do it.
Keep your mouth shut. Figured out
something that can be done. Thus,
a young leader when he finds himself
so situated that his command might be
disregarded,
must refrain from giving it.
He must first tried to change the
situation, capture the attention.
He must merely wait until he is reasonably
certain that when he gives us the
order,
it will indeed be obeyed.
So it makes sense.
And now we get into the
section called the leader.
And this is now where we start to come
towards the vision of leadership or the,
the principles of
leadership that I believe in
back to the book.
A good leader does not depend solely on
the authority that discipline gives him.
As an officer or noncommissioned officer
for good leadership goes far beyond
discipline. Look, good experience
leader inspires respect,
confidence,
and loyalty in his subordinates,
all of which enable him to get from his
men performance far above what a new
leader could command. So there you go.
All this stuff that we just talked about,
you've got to train them.
You got to have discipline.
You've got to make sure they're
going to obey your orders.
You got to teach him obedience.
All that stuff is nothing compared
to the power of respect of loyalty.
Continuing on in this,
the leader can rely on
the generous of his men.
For men have a natural longing to respect
and have affection for their leaders.
They want to be proud of their officers
and noncommissioned officers just as
they want to be proud of their unit
and their branch of service.
When the,
when the new army was first being formed,
many of the officers had
little experience in command.
They had learned the words were capable
of giving directions and instructions,
but they had learned neither the action
nor the manner that go with the command.
A young officer would utter an order,
but his manner would betray
his lack of confidence.
This uncertainty was in effect a signal
for not carrying the order out promptly
and effectively. As military orders
must be carried out all our lives,
we have depended on the manor and behavior
of others as well as on their speech
to know what is in their minds. Army
discipline cannot change human nature.
What did Sarah Armstrong say that 70%
of conveyed message in a conversation is
from like nonverbal,
nonverbal cues.
That's massive.
Yeah.
I wonder if that includes like
tone or not. I don't think it does.
Technically wouldn't cause
that's a verbal cue. Yeah,
so we know that whatever the number is,
it's a massive amount to a massive amount
that is conveyed by what your posture
is, what your delivery looks
like, what you're counting,
it's reads all those things and then
it lets include tone in it, right?
Which the tone should
be in there somewhere.
If you're giving orders and you look
like you don't know what you're doing and
your sound like you don't know you're
doing and you're using a tone that sounds
like you don't know what you're doing,
you're not going to get a lot of jumping
in there to execute what you're telling
me.
Yeah. Pie. That is nuts.
Because when you think about it,
I mean even saying that you start
to think about what at what,
like all the little things,
all of them that you're doing while
you're saying something or trying to say
something like even blinking,
like even if you blinked one time versus
10 times, just blinking that teeny,
teeny, tiny thing when you
said, you know, like Bruh,
it's like you're saying something
completely different. Even if, yeah.
Even though like when I'm talking to
people, I will not blink. I, yeah.
I noticed that very,
very early on in our relationship that
you don't really blame when you're
talking,
but I will look,
I [inaudible] the weird thing is is
I'm not consciously doing that kind of
thing. Yeah. But I do know that it's
happening. Yeah. And Man, when I,
when I first started making videos,
I noticed it a lot. So you know,
cause I noticed like villains
and characters, certain types,
quote unquote types of characters.
So one a villain.
When an actor is playing a villain and
he's saying something that's evil or
whatever and he's blinking
Brah I don't buy it at all.
It's the fact you kind of can't really
buy it. But if they're saying something,
what if it's important in whatever
way and they're not blinking.
It's almost like, man, that alone
sells it so much. Just that alone.
Of course there's other stuff,
but like, yeah, what? Blinking.
Even like wrinkling your forehead kind
of thing. Like all these little things.
So it goes so deep that you
know you can take two people.
One guy does hand motions
all the time and he just,
he moves his hands a lot when he talks
and the other guy does the exact opposite.
He moves his hands so little that
it's noticeable. It's not that,
oh he lacks verbal communication.
It's his INAC.
It's that his inaction is
his verbal communication.
See what I'm saying?
So it's not like he has less verbal
communication than the guy who uses his
hands.
He has just as much,
he's just saying something completely
different because he's still,
see what I'm saying?
So it's like just all these nonverbal
things that's deep pecos man. Yeah.
And this is where self awareness,
this is where role playing and
most important cause, cause look,
you're not gonna, you're not going to
become an academy award winning actor.
So what you actually need to do is
believe in what you're saying. Yeah.
That's what you need to do. Because if
you don't believe in what you're saying,
your troops are looking at you again,
he doesn't even believe this.
Why am I going to go charge this machine
gun nest when this guy doesn't even
believe that he should be
charged in this machine gun nest.
And yet if you truly believe
that this is what should go down,
people will see that you believe it
and they're going to follow. Yeah.
So how you feel about this? Because
it might be slightly separate. Okay.
So you know how people,
they'll give you the advice you want to,
you want to act confident. You want to
be confident when you do this stuff,
even if you're not confident or whatever.
So it's kind of like people can smell
when you're not confident and you're
acting confidence.
They way they can smell it when you're
trying to act casual or an actory lack
per how I can see, you
know, everyone can see that,
but if you do it enough,
doesn't it start?
Don't you get kind of good at it?
That's the advice that I give people
isn't go be confident when you talk to
people.
What I say is when you talk to people,
make sure you know what
you're talking about. Yeah.
Because if you know what you're talking
about, you will come across as confident.
Why will you come across as confident?
Because you are confident now.
Sure.
There's some people that have some
natural ability to act confident even when
they're not.
Yes,
and there's also some people that can
be very convincing and telling people to
do something that they don't actually
believe it. That's very rare.
It's very rare.
And even if I feel like those people,
and obviously I don't know
cause I don't know the people,
but it seemed like those are the people,
they're just used to doing it.
They're used to telling tall
tales with complete confidence,
but you can see how people,
if they repeat repeatedly
talk about the same thing.
Certainly they get better at it.
And can they take that
too far where they're just
turning into a robot that's up
there reciting something that
they've heard and people go,
oh this guy just got this memorized.
Cause that's jacked up too, right?
Like if you just go, oh, this guy's
just memorize this thing
and he's not really into it.
Right. That's not a good sign
either. Yeah. People can see
through that. Yeah. If he,
yeah. If it's like, yeah man,
u fan manufactured enthusiasm
or something like that. Yeah.
If they can smell it for sure. But because
some people like they'll memorize it.
Let's say if it's a speed,
obviously depends on the
context. Totally. But you know,
if it's a speech or a lecture or a
presentation that somebody get giving that
they always give and you know when they
talk about this Xyz exciting part or you
know, important part, they've
done it literally 10,000 times.
So they're not going to
convey natural excitement.
They have to sort of manufacture it
for the crowd kind of thing. And Yeah,
if that,
you know,
manufactured excitement comes off as
manufacturer to the cards yet that'll jam
yet Jim, your whole thing up. Yeah.
And I think that's why you have to be
talking about something that you know
about his part one and part two,
you have to be talking about
something that you care about.
If we don't care about you don't want
to hear me stand up and talk about
something, you know, some
whatever. You don't want it.
You don't want to hear me talk
about candle making sure. Right.
Cause I don't care about candle making.
In fact, I don't really like candles.
All right. I'm just being honest here. I
respect your opinion. Don't like candles.
Why would you have candles?
It's 2019 right?
Right. Well, there's many different
reasons for Kendall's. But yeah,
mood lighting. Uh, you know, my
point is I don't like candles.
You don't wanna hear
me talk about candles.
You don't hear me talk
about the construction of
candles because I don't care
about it and I'm not going to give a
very passionate talk about candles.
Even if I studied the subject matter.
If you hear me talking about leadership,
you can't harness the enthusiasm that
I have for talking about leadership.
You can't, you can't hold it back. It's
coming out unbridled. It's unbridled.
It's coming out because
I really care about this.
You know what I'm talking to a
bunch of people that are leaders.
I want them to win.
I want them to learn.
I want them to absorb what I'm saying
cause I know it can be helpful to them
cause I've seen it be helpful
to thousands of people.
So I want them to get the message and
so it's going to come out that way.
So I know what I'm talking about.
I believe what I'm talking about,
what I am talking about and I care
about what I am talking about.
And if you're talking to people,
try and talk about things
that you know about,
that you care about and that you believe
in. And if you do that as a leader,
when you're giving direction
and its direction that you
believe in its direction,
that you care about the outcome and its
direction that you know and understand
you are going to come across
like a confident leader
and people are gonna listen
to you. If you're failing
in those categories, it's
going to be harder for you.
This is interesting continuing on and we
just went on a little riff right there.
But a leader is actually
giving conflicting orders
if he is uncertain manner,
hints that he does not expect obedience
or that he thinks he may not be obeyed.
So even if you stand
up and you say it you,
you can be give conflicting
orders if you just don't,
if you just look like you're
unsure of what you're doing,
although it is possible for the new leader
who has lacked experience to imitate
the manner and tone of
wiser leaders around him,
only practice in command develops
the appropriate manner and tone.
And I would go further to say it's not
just about practice and you don't want to
become a good actor.
What you want to do is you want
to believe in what you're saying.
You want to care about what you think
would have no, no, but what you're saying
next, lack of a confident manner
inevitably interferes with command.
So also ma'am,
manner that portrays indecision for men
respond to the signs of indecision by
withholding or delaying action.
The rule is that a leader should make
up his mind and arrive at that decision
before he gives orders.
Okay?
Very obvious,
but not so obvious because people
screw it up when he confronts his man.
He must be ready to commit himself to
this course or that men will accept
assurance for competence and they do
not want competence and they do want
competence and leader. Now I, this
is again, this is a situation where I
men will accept assurance for competence.
That's not readily true
because just because you're,
if you're sure of yourself,
the only way you're going to be sure
of yourself is if you are competent.
Unless you're one of these small fractions
of people that are conmen, right?
Con Man that can be late,
the swollen gonna do everyone
like that's you're a con man.
If you're really good at that,
it can be aligned to people and telling
them something that you don't believe in,
fine. It'll work. Sometimes
if you're great at it might
work more often than that.
If you're a normal person and you
want to be a really good leader,
you shouldn't be just
using your confidence to
overcome the fact that you're
don't believe in what you're doing and
it's going to be really hard to do.
That is really hard to get.
People have really good lie
detectors in their minds. Hmm.
Okay.
This is a great section.
What soldiers think of leaders for the
first time in the history of armies.
The army of the United States has
undertaken to find out what its enlisted
personnel. Think about a large number
of things important to the army.
Some thousands of soldiers have been
interviewed at length and one of the
subjects about which they were
questioned his army leadership,
what the soldiers said makes it very
clear that the quality of leadership in an
army is the most important single
determiner of morale and performance.
Did everyone just hear that?
What soldiers said makes it very clear
that the quality of leadership in an army
is the most important single
determiner of morale and performance.
Okay.
What do we say now at echelon front,
we say leadership is the most
important thing on the battlefield.
I luckily don't have to pay the writer
of this book to say that cause that's the
same thing.
Leadership is the most important thing
on the battlefield is the single most
important determinant of
morale and performance.
Continuing on the relationship
between men and officers,
commissioned and noncommissioned
determines the fighting
spirit of an army quite
as much as the ability of the
soldiers to take training does.
In fact,
it turns out that these human relations
are much more important to morale than
beef, steak, warm socks, ballgames,
and Vaudeville shows or what
the men believe about the war.
What they think.
The relationship that you have with your
people is more important than all these
other things. It's more important than
their actual belief in what they're doing.
More important than
their belief in the war.
Continue on among the hundred and 50 so
items covered in in, in, in the interview.
77 proof to be definitely associated
with morale and of the 20 most closely
related to morale. 16 have to do
with man to officer relations,
what the men think of their leaders is
then of utmost importance to the army and
to the successful prosecution of the war.
Roughly in order of their association
with good leadership in the minds of the
enlisted men are the following points.
Three,
here's what makes a
good leader one ability.
Competence comes first.
The good officer must know his stuff for
on this depends the confidence in his
leadership.
Boom
and interestingly that is
proof of what I just said,
that if you don't believe in what you're
doing, you don't know what you're doing,
everyone's going to sense it.
So competence number one.
Number two next to the ability next to
ability is interested in the welfare of
the soldier.
The officer who can be trusted to help
the soldier in time of need or who would
be accessible for personal advice
is a good officer. So you've gotta,
you gotta be caring about your men.
Number three,
promptness in making decisions is next.
Number four,
good teacher or instructor follows the
leader who has the patience and the
ability to make things clear,
to get men under him. Dope.
To get to make things clear to the men
under him is valued for that reason.
So you've got gotta be good teacher.
Number five, judgment, common sense,
and the ability to get things done,
follow in next judgment and common sense.
Isn't it an interesting common sense?
You know what we want,
even once you have some common sense
and that horribly,
a cliched saying of common sense
sometimes isn't very common.
And it's a cliche because it's true.
Yes.
How many times I've been sitting in
a big meeting, you know what I mean?
Here in the city
thing that was so obvious.
So it's just such common sense.
And had people
kind of jaw drop at
this amazing statement,
which was completely obvious cause
sometimes common sense isn't too common.
It's only common to you.
It's like relative, you know?
That's why it's never like
an shouldn't say never,
but it's not that good of an an idea
generally threatened to be like it's
Commons or MB like mad at someone for not
knowing quote unquote common sense. No,
it's not good and it's not good when you,
when you make a statement that is
common sense to say it condescendingly
like this is just common sense.
Everyone you need to do this and
then everyone already is mad at you.
They're resentful of you yet just
from the tone alone, the tone alone.
Then on top of that dimension you've
got your arms crossed and you're shaking
hand Sarah Armstrong verbal cue cues.
Just,
yeah,
Mensa because common sense in California
is different than common sense in
Texas. Some of it possibly. Oh yeah. Yeah.
Common Sense in Texas is different than
California. I'll tell you. It's true.
That's a good point. You are
correct. So you can, yeah,
the number's going to be on you
when you start doing that stuff.
The condescending deal.
Here we go.
Number six,
the good leader does not boss you around
when there is no good reason for it.
Soldiers dislike an officer
who throws his rank around,
who test his own authority continually.
They sense that he is not sure of himself.
Let that one sink in.
If you're bossing people around using
your rank to make things happen,
you're people don't like you. Yeah.
And there's someone that says,
I'm not here for my people to
like you like me. You're wrong.
If your people don't like you,
they will not perform as well as people
that do like you. And you're the leader.
Number seven,
the man who tells you when you have done
a good job rates well as a good leader.
Failure in commendation is a common
complaint among men in the ranks.
The best incentive to good work is the
prospect that it will be noticed and
remembered by the leader
solid
next. And um, that's something I
don't do a lot of. I'm not like, okay,
good job buddy. But I will say that when
I do tell someone they did a good job,
they know that I mean it. They're usually
pretty fired up that I said it to him.
Yeah, I would agree
with that. Number Eight,
physical strength and good build.
Come next.
You're nodding your head over there.
Echo Charles.
I Agree Jack. I mean, okay so
at risk of sounding like maybe
disparaging any one in particular,
any type person in particular,
but I'm just saying this is like
factually so you ever watch it like a self
defense video? Yes. And no matter what,
yes I fall a mic go Joe life
LR and Joe Rogan repost those
mic Dojo life things. But yeah,
there's all kinds of weird self defense
things and I know where you're going
with this. Yes. So
physical self defense guy,
he doesn't look like he could what?
Make it up a flight of stairs
and you're thinking, Bro,
I'm not going to listen to anything that
you say. Right. Which detective Lee,
his physique does not prove the
effectiveness of his, his tenant is true.
It doesn't.
But what about when he's got the sign
hanging up in the background that says
honor, strength and discipline
and only discipline.
He has put in putting away that
quarter pounders with cheese daily
and that that's, that's the
point, you know, so it's
like bright. It is something,
and I, again, I don't want to disparage
anyone system or whatever, but yeah man,
if I'm a soldier or a listener or a
follower and I'm going to do first
impression,
right?
I come up to you and you're going to
teach me something and you're like,
oh sloppy, you're a sloppy person. I'll
tell you. That's at the very least,
that's a strike against.
There's no doubt about it.
And they're just just even me and
Ramadi and telling all my guys,
hey you will wear a square to wear
uniform because first impressions mean
something.
And so if somebody shows up
to be in charge of you and
they can't take charge of
their own health, it's an indicator
that maybe they got some other issues.
Especially,
I mean then this is clearly directed at
people that are in the military because
military is a physical job.
Re pretty much,
regardless of what you're
doing in the military,
you have to have some physical capability
to put on a rucksack and go and walk
for a long period of time.
You've gotta be able to do these
certain physical activities.
And if it's apparent from looking
at you that you can't do that,
respect is going down. And by the way,
this isn't, this isn't me talking,
this isn't you talking.
This is what these thousands of soldiers
that filled out this survey said, hey,
physical strength and good build,
come next. That's what's respected.
And it's definitely not mandatory because
I mean, Napoleon was like a tiny guy,
right? So it's not a mandatory thing, but
don't be out of shape. I can tell
you that. Yeah, get in shape.
Hey, get in shape. How's that? If
you're not in shape, get in shape.
It'll be better for you as a leader.
It will be better for
you as a human being it.
It'll help everything that you're
doing. So do it. Number nine,
good education,
sense of humor and guts or courage.
Number 10 impartiality is next.
Leaders who do not save the dirty jobs
for fellows. They don't like our valued.
The good leader is fair to all
in his command, so be fair.
Common Sense,
which I guess isn't too
net next and an importance is industry
leaders who do as little work as they can
get away with are not respected
by the enlisted men. Yeah,
don't be standing around with your hands
in your pockets cause to home do that.
12 when an officer gives orders in such
a way that you clearly know what to do
is a mark of merit as a leader.
Soldiers also like an officer
with a clear strong voice.
There you go.
That makes sense.
The remaining qualities which the soldiers
mentioned came toward the bottom of
the list.
They are undoubtedly related to good
leadership but they are less important.
Not Hot tempered.
Do not drive you too hard.
Keep promises.
The kind of fellows you
could have a good time with,
not too proud of their rank
are all characteristics
which some men want in their
leaders, but there is no
general agreement about them.
Many leaders are considered good in
spite of failures on these parts.
The chief things a man wants from a
leader are thus competence and interest in
his welfare.
The orders of a man who does not know
his stuff cannot be dependent on,
they are subject to change and countermand
an incompetent leader teaches caution
and hesitation and following his lead,
he becomes a signal for lack of
action on the part of the soldier.
Indecision in a leader has the same
effect on a soldier as ignorance has no
soldier can follow.
A leader who's uncertain,
which way to turn the essential quality
of any leaders to take lead and show the
direction quickly, clearly,
emphatically, and with enthusiasm.
Without these qualities, a man is not
even a good leader for his hunting dog.
Now the interesting thing
about that is there's a,
there's a little dichotomy that
reveals itself. It's like, okay,
you gotta be decisive and
give direction quickly,
clearly and emphatically that
that's great. That sounds good.
What happens if you're not sure what
happens if you're truly not sure which
direction to go?
Then what you do is you say hold up
former perimeter where we got
to get a resection on the map.
That is so much better than saying,
all right,
well we're going to push a little further.
You know what I mean?
Like I'm not really sure where we are
and hold on and wait. If you just go,
hey look,
we're a little turned around right now.
We're need to recouple resections
where to check the GPS,
whatever we're going to do,
when to find out where we're on the,
we're gonna move forward to take five.
It never goes uncle Jack has got this
under wraps were good technically that is
being decisive. It is being decisive. Yes,
you can be decisive in intro in trying
to uncover what the next move is going to
be cause you're not sure,
but sometimes people try and you know bs
their way through a scenario like that
and that again, you're, you're,
you don't know what you're doing and
you're proving that so it's best to be
truthful and say, hey look,
we're turned around right now.
We're going to form a perimeter,
we're going to cut a resection,
we're going to find out where we
are and then we're going to move.
You got 10 minutes. Boom. Everyone
was okay. Cool. Good Times.
So those,
that is a great list of what,
what people look for from leaders and
sure it's directed at the military,
but almost every single one of those
is equally applicable to any leadership
position. Next, the role of the soldier,
part of what makes a man a good soldier,
his own, his, his own
adoption of the soldiers role.
He comes to think and speak
of himself as a soldier.
What a man thinks of himself affects
his behavior. The rail straightener,
which is the skilled worker who runs the
machine that straightens railroad rails
is one man.
When he thinks of himself with
pride as a rail straightener,
he becomes another when he begins as he
made to regard himself as a mere wage
slave. The rail straightener takes
pride in his work, does a good job,
is happy the wage slave let's crooked
rails get by because he doesn't care the
same way the soldier who thinks proudly
of himself as a soldier is doing a
service to both himself and the army.
How smart is that?
That is very good.
Yeah.
So it's like you're kind of
introducing a sense of identity, right?
And they like their job, like this is
what you do and people will do that.
You know, the for themselves,
you know, I'm a whatever.
I remember some time,
this is actually quite a while ago,
somebody posted a picture of a very
intricate plumbing job and it was like 8
million copper pipes and perfectly
spaced coming in. And I was like,
this dude is proud to be a plumber
and it's lunch shows budget.
So yes,
if you are in a job,
get into the job, right.
And let me tell you this,
if you're not into the job and
you want to get out of the job,
the best way for you to get out of the
job is by getting into the job you're
doing something that you don't care about,
care about it.
Because otherwise people look at you.
Why would I promote you? You can't even,
you can't even dig this ditch correctly.
If you're out there digging
that ditch like you,
like you mean it like you'd make trying
to make a perfect dish in the world.
Do it.
Yeah.
Certain forms of punishment
published just public disgrace,
ridicule all the role of the soldier and
may lessen or destroy his usefulness to
the army and his,
uh,
amenability to leadership
the noncommissioned or
commission officer who rides
one of his men in such a manner as to
make him doubt his own value as a soldier
is shattering the man's best
motive for good performance.
The senior leader who reprimands a
junior in the presence of his man reduces
that junior's value to the army.
Almost never good to the little
someone in front of the team.
Good leadership.
On the other hand causes men to build
up each for himself a particular role,
a specialty.
It means a great deal to a man to take
pride in being a soldier into being a
sharp shooter, an aviation mechanic, a
truck driver, a cook or a radio operator.
Competent leaders criticize a,
a poor piece of work.
Condemn a mistake but never take but
take care of to never make a soldier feel
he is a failure at his job.
So you can criticize the mistake that
they made but don't criticize their, uh,
their ability in that job.
When a soldier begins to regard himself
as being part of his unit and when his
job has become part of his role,
then teamwork has enormously improved.
The soldier who thinks of himself as only
a private temporarily on this or that
assignment is a different man from
the soldier who thinks of himself as a
necessary member of his outfit.
Good information. And here's how
we get to selection of leaders.
Rank is no guarantee of the ability
to judge leadership in others,
nor are good leaders necessarily competent
to assess good leadership and others.
The test of competent judge is his
successful predictions in the past.
Okay,
so you might be the highest ranking guy,
but that doesn't mean you can necessarily
figure out who's going to be a good
leader unless you show repetitively
that you can select good leaders.
The interview itself is not a fair
or accurate test of the soldier,
the man who would make a good leader,
maybe a modest man who fails in an
interview to exhibit those qualities that
would make his men believe in him,
trust him,
and admire him and the man who could
never secure the loyalty of serve
subordinates may nevertheless be by
assurance and poise by voice and manner,
mislead inexperienced
judges as to his capacity.
So all the time I get asked, what
should we, how should I interview?
What should I ask?
You can only figure out so much fruit.
And when I get asked
that, I always say, okay,
who in here thought they were hiring
the best guy that they've ever hired?
And he turned out to be a loser
and everyone raises their hand.
And how many times have you taken a
chance on someone that you weren't sure if
they're going to work out and
they turned out to be a stud?
Everyone raises their hand.
Yeah.
It's really hard to judge who's
going to work well and who's not.
And that kind of goes for like
friends too. You know, like they're,
I mean man that happens all the time
where you meet someone and you just know
you don't really feel them that much,
but they end up being your best friend
or something like that like years later
or something like that. It's
weird like that, like situations,
even certain first impressions,
you know,
that that are like they don't indicate
the long haul, you know? Yeah,
yeah.
It takes a little bit time to uncover
what people are real about really about in
many cases I can tell you like I feel
pretty good about judging people. Yeah.
And I'm probably like 70% accurate,
you know? So that's not a great,
like I feel pretty good about it, but
I know that I'm only battened 70% yeah.
Which is like a c,
but the,
I wonder if in do you think this,
do you think that there's certain things
that are maybe even subconscious about
people that you can sorta tell after
just talking to him for a second,
whether it be like for sure they react to,
I'm going to ask,
this just popped up my mind. I got
asked, I was at a event and it wasn't,
it was interesting about it.
It wasn't with a specific company,
which normally are working with a company
and I was just at an event where I'm
speaking to multiple different companies
and this woman stood up to ask a
question and as soon as
she stood up I was like,
this is going to be she,
she does not want to hear my
answer no matter what I say.
But she just stood up with just
arrogance dripping off her and,
and just, I was like, well, she's not
gonna. She's not gonna like this answer.
Whatever answer I give, whatever
question she asks, she is not,
she's not listening.
So that,
that thought that you had right
there when it comes correct? Yeah,
it was basically when she stood up
and then three words out of her mouth,
I was like, for real here.
I was like, yeah. And,
and it's also interesting
because you know, she just,
when you're working with a single company,
they're all kind of on board and
they're all kind of like, they're,
maybe they're not on board
with what you're saying,
but they're unified as a group trying
to move in a certain direction.
So we have a random group of people and
the woman stands up and I could tell
right away, yep, she's got it.
She does. She, there's no answer.
I'm going to give her, that's going to
make her happy. What did it feel like?
It was like subconscious,
like what's it like or where
you like see the visual cues?
It was visual cues and then
the opening of the question,
and I can't remember what it was,
but it was like, Oh yes, confirmed,
let me tell you. So it was one of
those, it was one of those, you know,
and so what I did was I preempted my
answer and I said, you're, you know,
cause then she asked
a question and I said,
you're actually not going to
like my answer to this question,
but I'm just going to tell you what I've
seen. And I appreciate the question.
And then I answered the question.
And of course she didn't like the answer.
You don't know why she didn't like
the answer because the answer was the
leadership question.
And the problem with the people that
you're having is not a problem with the
people that you have.
It's a problem with you,
which is the way it is with
all leadership problems.
When you have a problem with your team,
your team isn't performing the way you
want them to do. It's, it's, it's, oh,
they're lazy. Oh, they don't
do the mission correctly.
Well, whose fault is that?
You're the leader.
You're the leader in charge of the people.
So if they're not doing the mission that
you want them to execute it or how you
want them execute it, you can't blame
them. They literally work for you.
You are the boss of them.
So let's list, look,
do you want to explain to me how you give
them the direction you want to talk to
me about like what,
what sort of direction you give them,
how you communicate with them. And
we went down that road, you know,
but at the end of the
day she sat down with no,
she took nothing.
I said onboard zero.
And this is a fairly rare occasion,
you know, that's why I remember,
this was a couple of years ago, but
I remember it because I thought, Yup,
she didn't. She's, when
she stood up, I set up,
she's not listening to me and then
she's not gonna like my answer.
And then when she sat down I said, Yup,
she's going to walk out of here and go,
that guy didn't know what he was
talking about. This, it's not my,
it's not my problem that my team
is all jacked up. It's not my,
it's not my fault that my team is lazy.
One of her key components of her statement
was that her team was lazy and they
weren't meeting the standards. And the
answer to that question isn't, you know,
beat them harder cause that doesn't work.
The answer that question is you as a
leader are not doing a good job of leading
them or there is a chance that your team
is completely incompetent and you need
to train them or get rid of them.
Guess what?
Both of those things are your
responsibility. You're the leader.
You need to train them or
you need to get rid of them.
So worse answering the
world isn't the best.
It's the worst dancer in the world. It
hurts, you know, life talks about this,
Dave talks about like when he was like,
when he's writing,
no bad teams,
only bad leaders.
He's literally thinking about things that
he did where he was blaming his team,
you know, and he's just looking
and he's looking back on here.
I was blaming my team and in none
of it was my fault. And that's,
that's the revelation that you have.
I've seen literally witnessed this and
like a bunch of times too where people
would stand up,
which with what I thought was sort of
that sort of feel that tone, like, oh,
like they're gonna,
they're just gonna Stump.
You Miss [inaudible] mister know
it all, you know, kind of attitude.
And you tell him that answer. Like it's
like, hey, it's your responsibility.
You know?
And then I can see their mind just
totally changing you and they accept it.
And actually going back to this woman,
when I was talking to this woman,
I immediately tried to like frame it in
the most humble way to not offend her
ego. You know, when I told
them, when I told her, you know,
you're not going to like the answer I
give you. I didn't say it like that.
I was like, look, I'm going
to give you an answer that I,
I got a feeling you're probably
not even gonna like this answer,
but I just going to tell you
kind of what I've seen, you know?
So I tried to do my best to
not hit her ego in the face.
The problem was her ego was big and
strong and dug in and leading the way
leading out front. And
so it was, you know,
and that always bums me out and it
doesn't happen very often. Like I said,
I mean this is two years ago or something
like that and I'm remembering this
person asking this question,
I'm trying to think of myself that she
doesn't want to hear what I'm going to do.
What she wanted me to say
is, yeah, you're right,
your team is so horrible
and the exception, you know,
they're probably just hate, you know the
world and they don't want to do like,
like you know what it is.
They probably don't want to do a good job.
They probably don't want to get promoted.
They probably don't want
to make any extra money.
They probably want to go home
unsatisfied with your job. That's their,
that's their deal.
Right.
And I'm sorry that you've been burdened
with this horrible team that feels that
way. Yeah. Right. Cause that's
absolutely true. You don't have a whole,
you might have one or two people on
your team that aren't very enthusiastic,
but you're not going to have a whole
team that no one wants to do. Good job.
No one wants to put in any extra effort.
No one wants to work hard,
but you don't have a whole team like that.
And by the way,
if you do have a team like that gas,
what it is your responsibility to get rid
of those members that don't want to do
what they need to do to win.
Yeah.
A lot of times when it happens,
when I lead people down that that
question, they'll be like, hey, you know,
I've got this department, and
I'll say, oh, okay, well you know,
I got this department and they got these,
these mid level managers and they're
all horrible. I'm like, oh, well that's,
that's terrible. Who, who's in
charge of the mid level managers? Oh,
well it's this guy. Okay, who's
in charge of that guy? Oh,
this other guy who's in charge
of that guy. Well, I am.
Okay, so whose fault is this
man? Yeah, it's your fault.
It's truly your fault.
Right?
Funny, you'll do this technique,
which I always find pretty impressive.
Like as far as the little chip,
it's almost like a,
it's not a chess game cause it's not
you against the asker of the question,
but there's an element to it.
We're just like that.
Like how you'd like make them answer
their own questions kind of thing. Where,
but you'll go, you'll say, oh, do you,
do you think that they just
want to do a bad job? And
they'd be like, oh no, no, no,
no, nothing like that. Oh,
do you think that like, um,
that they want your company to fail the,
you know,
those questions that goes up and down the
chain of command to cause some of like,
well, my boss doesn't do this. I'm like,
did you think of your boss wants
to lower your profitability?
Do you think your boss wants you
to do things that are less safe?
You think your boss wants you to have
people leaving on a regular basis?
Do you think your boss wants more
turnover? Do you think your boss,
you go right down the list? And of
course it's, no, no, no, no, no.
And eventually you realize,
oh look so calm.
Here's me cause I'm not communicating
well enough to explain to my boss when I
need. Yes, that's a good one. But it's,
it's good to also not only
as like something fun to
kind of watch or whatever,
but um, you know, so you watched
them kind of gain understanding.
That is cool for sure.
But it helps because it helps
even me or people like put it into
perspective. You know, like men, no
one's against you bro. You're like, hey,
you know, make some right moves in,
say some right things and men get up,
get on the same page.
And by the way,
most of the time when someone is against
you, because there are times, you know,
you got that person that's a,
just wants to get promoted and they're
looking to step all. It's like,
do a good job, do a great
job, keep working hard,
make them look good. What are you talking
about? No, you make them look good.
It will come back.
It will come back
back to the book.
The only proof of leadership is leadership
and the best thing to do is give it a
chance to emerge and then have competent
men judge whether it has appeared.
So this is another,
it's just hard to know what people are
like until you actually put them in this
situation. Although young men
can make excellent leaders,
leadership develops with experience,
no doubt about that.
It is known moreover that the men
have a platoon can size each other up,
effectively,
can pick out men who deserve advancement
more consistently than leaders camp
the men. No competence
when they see it. Thus,
it appears that the officer who fails
to find out quietly the opinions of his
subordinates when he is selecting a man
for promotion is overlooking a valid
source of information.
One that is in the long run,
far more accurate than his own judgment.
So listen to your people
leader.
Next section.
Very important or important
leadership can be learned.
There are no born leaders.
All leadership is based on
learning how to deal with men.
Nearly all leaders improve after they
have had some experience in command.
Some improved faster than others and
some continued to improve while others do
not.
So there are no born leaders.
Okay, we know my debate on this,
I actually disagree with that.
Well I should say this.
Okay,
there might not be born leaders but there
are people that are born with certain
aptitudes with for a variety
of leadership qualities.
And somebody posted something on social
media that said there's an a gene,
there is a gene that you have or don't
have as a human being that relates to
your ability to articulate.
So guess what?
If you are born with that dream Jean
and you have a high level ability to
articulate and communicate
with other human beings,
you are born with more
aptitude to become a leader.
Could you end up still being
a terrible leader? Yes.
Cause there's some people that are very
articulate that are horrible leaders,
but it is one attribute that you are
born with doesn't necessarily make you a
leader. Right? It gives you more aptitude
to be a leader. So maybe that is correct.
You're not born a leader,
but you're born with a little more
aptitude to be a leader. Back to the book,
consider the qualities which enlisted
men believe important in leaders.
The first is competency and ability.
Competence is based on learning.
The good leader has learned
his job thoroughly, so there
you go. That makes sense.
His men can trust him
to know what he's doing.
He knows not only what he
learned in his training courses,
but he's kept it up to date.
If he has an artillery man,
he knows how the Germans use
artillery and what guns they have.
The s the rule is a simple one.
Know your stuff so that I agree with you.
Learn to be competent.
Second to competence is the officer's
interest in the soldier as a man,
a demonstrated interest that gives the
soldier confidence that when he stands up
to hardship or is in trouble,
the hardship is a necessary
part of the job and his troubles
give his officer concerns.
So you've got to care about your people.
And actually what's interesting about
this whole section, if you remember this,
is this is saying there's no born leaders,
but there's a whole section in the first
part of this book that talks about Pete
men have different aptitudes and skills
that they either have or they don't
have. And some of it had
to do with, you know,
you are a truck driver
in the civilian sector,
so you're gonna make a good
truck driver in the military.
But it also talked about
how some people aren't,
don't have the aptitude for certain jobs.
So they're being a little bit
hypocritical here just a little bit.
Okay,
so we're talking about caring about
people and here it says every man can buy,
can buy,
practice,
improve his skill in human understanding
and increased his repertoire of actions
that demonstrate interest in others.
The rule here is low, is less simple.
It is know your men and show it. No their
names, their history, their weaknesses,
their good points there. Morale begin
by studying their qualification cards.
So that's another skill
that you can get better at.
Decisiveness is a skill harder to acquire,
but it can with attention be it
cultivated. When you have a hard choice,
remember, you do not usually
have to make a snap judgment.
Careful consideration.
Weighing the merits of alternate
courses is not indecision.
Your men will respect your
judgement even more if you deserve.
If you reserve decision until you are
in possession of all the facts necessary
for a wise choice,
do not set up a council of
war to pass things by vote.
You are the leader,
but seek advice when you need it.
And do not hesitate to call on your
subordinates for council if they are
qualified to give it. But choose your
course before you give the orders,
which we already heard. So there's,
and this is also a little bit contrary,
we're not contrary, but this is an
addendum to what was being said earlier,
that you gotta be decisive. And here
is saying, look, you gotta be decisive,
but you can take your time.
You want to measure everything out.
Another suggest,
another suggestion to the leader
is remember when you're men,
do not understand you
that it is your fault.
You must talk their language,
plain language.
If you cannot express yourself clearly,
it may be because you do not
understand the subject to yourself.
Think things through carefully before
you try to explain. So there you go.
A little extreme ownership,
a little simplicity in there.
A leader then to be worthy in the eyes
of his men would do well to follow these
commands. Number one, be competent.
Number to be loyal to your men as
well as to your country and army.
Number three, know your men. Understand
them. Love them. Be Proud of them.
Number four,
accept responsibility and
give clear decisive orders.
Yeah.
Number five,
teach your men by putting them
through the necessary action.
Number six, give only
necessary orders. Bought.
Number seven,
get things done.
Number Eight, be fair.
Number nine, work hard.
Number 10 remember that a leader is a
symbol men need to respect and trust.
You.
Don't let them down.
Yeah,
so there you go.
They they wrap it all back into
from everything we started started this
thing talking about when you're talking
about discipline and obedience.
Hmm.
This whole thing about being a leader
has nothing to do with obedience.
It has to do with being a good leader.
Yeah,
and that's how they wrap up that chapter.
That's
solid information in there.
Now this next section is about mobs and
panic and what's interesting about this
is as a human being in
charge of other human beings,
you have to understand how mobs and
panic on fold going back to the book,
men and a mob act just as much in keeping
with their past training and habits as
they would if they were alone.
But part of this training which men get
from earliest childhood is to follow the
example of other individuals and
also to respond to their gestures,
facial expressions and tones of voice
as well as other as well as the spoken
words of others. That's an
interesting concept, isn't it?
It's a little trick statement
because what it's saying is, hey,
when you've got a mob of people,
they are acting in accordance
with how they've been trained,
but then you think yourself wasn't in the
army, then they wouldn't act that way.
But then it goes on to say they'd been
trained since day one to imitate people.
So you're actually fighting against
the rest of their training when you're
trying to get them to not do
something that everyone else is doing.
And by the way,
it's,
it's an important thing that usually is
beneficial and it goes into some of that
here.
When a soldier misunderstands a command,
he starts to execute it
as he interpreted it.
But suppose in the middle of a movement,
he become suddenly aware that the other
men in ranks are doing something very
different. Immediately he corrects his
action to do what others are doing.
So most of the time it's beneficial.
That little mob mentality,
in the same way,
the site of a leader running or galloping
to the rear in a combat area may start
a whole company heading
after him on the double.
His example can become as much a
command as or order as his words.
Mostly. It is a good thing that men
naturally follow the example of others.
It makes the world run more smoothly. Yet
the good principal has vicious results.
When mobs form or panic starts.
Why mobs for moms form because some one
event or condition has brought people
together and captured the attention
of every person in the crowd.
Usually the mom is angry about
something and it is and it's angry.
Excitement makes it ready for action.
Panic based on fear is something else.
So a differentiate between the mob that
is angry and the mob that is afraid.
That's panicking besides a
common focus of attention.
So that's one element is the
Emotion is characteristic of all mobs.
Since a mob is driven by powerful emotion,
it is not necessarily
crazy to do something.
It wants action so it only takes a cry
of Lynch him or burn it to set the mob in
motion. Mostly when you get
into a crowd you join it,
you do just what other people do.
The site of others,
seizing stones or starting an attack.
So grips the men watching them that
they think of no other course of action
mobs.
Therefore our uncritical
interesting statements about mobs.
I'm trying to think when have
you been a part of a mob before?
No, I mean in that regard, no,
I've been at some shows and by that I
mean hardcore shows back in the day where
the mob would start to get something,
you know,
like whether it was breaking
down a barrier and yeah,
you get swept up in that mob mentality.
It's group think
this one's talking about panic.
Soldiers do not often for mobs,
mob action among soldiers usually
occurs when they are away from the usual
reminders in circumstances of discipline
when they are on leave and mingling
with men from our,
the organization's without leadership,
but panic can occur in the best
drilled. Thirdly, season troops,
it can occur in the midst of combat.
Some of the greatest routes in
history have been cases of panic.
The panicked group is much like a
mob, but it acts from fear, not anger.
It's attention is focused
on the object of fear.
It's thought and it's talk is of danger
and disaster. It's aim is escape.
Action becomes definite and mob like
only when obstacles to escape are
encountered.
It doesn't take much to set off a
panic among troops who are panic ripe.
Then a single cry of gas or run or we're
caught off may start a mad flight and
here it talks about panic ripeness.
Anything that makes men tense on edge,
jittery and over sensitive
to slight noises,
half hidden sites or sudden movements,
we'll make them easy victims of panic.
For this reason,
prolonged anxiety makes men panic ripe,
so does over fatigue,
too much beer or liquor or a hangover.
So does lack of proper food,
especially deficiency of B vitamins and
so does exhaustion from lack of sleep.
Prolonged exposure to noise and alarm
of modern battle may produce the jumpy
state of mind from which panic arises.
One main cause of panic
is lack of training.
Training must cover practice and defense
and retreat as well as in attack.
If panic is to be avoided if the
retreat is not to turn into a route,
the sight of one or several
men running to the rear,
the site of others
throwing away their gear.
Weapons may cause a general scramble
and discarding of arms bad morale is
another cause of panic. Rumor sometimes
plays an important part in Redding.
Men for panic.
Poor leadership can make
the ground ready for panic,
impairing the confidence and
command necessary to hold
troops to the performance
of duty. How to stop a panic.
This is very important.
Once a panic has begun,
the only way to Holt it is to
capture attention and then provide,
provide positive,
clear commands.
Leaders must act with decision,
firmness and courage.
If no officer is present,
any self possessed man can
assume leadership and give
the scared men what they
need. Clear, confident direction.
So I think the important is
to import important parts.
You've got to get their attention and
then you got to give simple, clear,
concise commands, positive commands
and then it goes on to say,
but the best way to stop a panic
is never to have it at all.
Train all men through release so that
they have confidence in themselves,
their leaders, their weapons. Train their
leaders and select the best of them.
Let good leaders build up good morale,
avoid hunger,
thirst and boredom as much as possible
to do in war and all the conditions that
lead to nervous tension and complaint.
If you could not avoid them.
And war is no bed of roses.
Fight them with good morale.
Fight the feeling of insecurity.
Tell the men all they need to know.
Let them know all possible information
about the enemy, where he is,
what he is like, how we attacks, what
weapons he is using. Last but not least,
build up faith. Be sure the
men know why they are fighting,
why it is a good cause.
Let them be sure that their
officers are with them all the way.
Faith in an ideal plus faith
in your leaders plus faith
in other fellows in your
unit can win victory
against superior forces.
Okay,
so there you go. You got to
watch out for that. Next section.
Differences among races and people's
modern total war has placed a new
responsibility on the shoulders,
shoulders of the soldier once his
only task was to destroy the enemy.
But now psychological warfare
requires him to play a new role.
He must help when allies for
Uncle Sam in many strange lands,
and this is what's interesting,
we always think of world war well.
We think of World War Two for
sure as, hey, this is total war.
You're not worried about hearts
and minds, which was, you know,
the campaign it in really in
Vietnam it was hearts and minds.
It's where that kind of originated
and certainly in Iraq and Afghanistan,
we think all those guys didn't have
to deal with this back in the day.
You have to deal with this.
Now we are.
We have to worry about the
civilian populace and all this.
Guess what we're wrong. Hmm.
1942 they're talking about this
and it goes into,
there are no infallible recipes for
making friends the world around.
But there are two basic rules for all
soldiers in the manual of psychological
arms. Number one, mind your manners.
Number two, understand and
respect the manners of strangers,
especially strangers who might help both
you and the cause for which you were
fighting seems pretty obvious.
Hmm.
And no one thinks that in world war
two they had to watch their manners,
but you do.
Next one talking about race,
color of the skin is often the basis
for prejudice because it is so clearly a
badge of difference between people's,
uh,
mark that sets one people apart as
different as not one of us American whites
have been prejudice not only against
blacks skins but also against yellow and
against copper skins
of the American Indian.
The United States excluded both
jabs and Chinese from immigration.
When our western states became afraid
of their cheap labor and the old German
Kaiser invented the slogan,
the yellow peril,
when he wished to unite
Europe against the Asiatics.
And what I find interesting about this
whole thing is this is 1942 so this is
pre civil rights movement in America
and yet we find the military forward
leaning on civil rights and we'll get to
that.
Sometimes the prejudice against
the negroes flares up in the army.
It is not a problem.
However,
in a camp where it is well understood
that a soldier in the United States
uniform is a soldier,
not a white or a Negro Christian
or Jew rich man or poor,
but a soldier.
And as such worthy of respect
and not everyone feels race prejudice.
There are plenty of white men who are
constantly meeting and working with black,
brown and yellow men of education,
culture, brain's inability.
These white men know that skin color is
not a sign of inferiority or superior or
superiority and they tend to forget about
it or at least to regard it is or at
least regarded as unimportant.
These white men are numerous in Europe,
South America,
Asia and Africa where the races are
mixed up in business and in politics.
Yeah,
the American soldier will be on the
right track when he realizes that the
differences are superficial,
that other races while different from
his own or not necessarily inferior,
he will know that he cannot tell just
from a man's color whether that man will
bind up his wounds, guide him to a
hospital when he his last feed him.
If he is hungry or help
them repel enemy invaders,
it will help him to remember that skin
color in itself means nothing about the
intelligence, wisdom, honesty,
bravery or kindliness of a man.
If he studies carefully the people
of other races whom he meets,
he can satisfy himself that this is true.
So again,
1942 pre civil rights and
the military is saying,
Hey, guess what folks?
Race doesn't matter.
And by the way,
still a segregated army,
but
they're moving in the right direction.
How to win friends in foreign lands.
Every American soldier in a foreign
land becomes an American diplomat.
He has his role to play in making
strange people into Americans,
America's friends. Here's some
rules he will find helpful. Again,
this is so interesting to read because
I'm telling you when you're in the
military you think all these guys
back to the night team, World War Two,
they didn't have to worry about that and
we just went over there and kicked ass
shit. And it's like here they were
getting the briefs. This is the brief.
This is the big brief
and here's some things that that
will help you be a good diplomat.
Yeah,
and this is applicable like this is
when you go and work with a new company,
guess what you want to, you want, you
do want to win the hearts and minds.
Here's a couple tips. One, try.
First of all the understand strange
customs habits and ways of thinkings.
Number two,
respect these customs and
habits of thought even when
you can't understand them
and even when they seem
unpleasant or a feminine or crazy.
Three when you cannot
respect foreign countries,
then suppress your disapproval,
stifle your emotions.
When you can respect foreign customs,
show it.
You can win many friends for
America in this simple way. Five,
when you associate with foreign
people try to adopt their manners.
Do not ask them to adopt yours.
Okay.
Suppress your own peculiarities as far
as possible when they are contrary to the
customs of the land.
Yeah.
Number seven,
when foreign customs or none of your
business in mind only your own business.
Number eight,
be friendly after all,
the only way to make other men like
you is to like them. And number nine,
take people as they come
like them for what they are,
not for the way they happen,
to measure up to your own standards,
what you expected of them.
So really good guidance
just in general for humans.
Those interesting there,
there,
what did, what did he say? If it's like
if their customs or a feminine or, yeah,
so I remember what I was learning Spanish
in high school and they were talking
about there's a difference between
Spanish in Spain and Mexico and different,
you know,
it's a different
Castilian Spanish versus that's what
they speak in Spain. Oh, for real? Yeah.
And in Mexico they speak, I don't
know if they call it Mexican Spanish.
Hmm. But it's fast still. I remember,
you know, in part of the,
you know, the course, um,
they were talking about different
customs and stuff like that. So I guess,
you know, in, in Spain they say the
SS with a list like a tea or disease,
it's just a little bit. Yeah. Um,
but there was this one custom that I
can remember that they're like, oh yeah.
It's not uncommon to see like men holding
hands when they're free. You know,
how like, Hey your, do you have your
hand? Right guys? Just holding hands.
That's how you know. And um, I remember
thinking that's interesting. You know,
because that's something that's really
far from custom here. Yeah. Yeah.
But we will have her
hand like our arm around,
you know when you're a kid you
got your arms around your boys.
Yeah. But you're not, you're
not just walking around
like that sometimes I guess.
I don't know when you're, you're
doing it. Okay. You're a kid. Yeah.
You're walking off the football
field after a good play. Sure.
You might have your arm
around. You're right. Yeah.
You're not walking down the sidewalk.
Cater to a movie with your arm. Right.
Your buddy that's not happening.
Yes. So you're right. And that,
that custom of holding hands
is really common throughout.
Like dude's holding hands is a real
common throughout the rest of the world.
Like lots of different places do
that. Yeah. And it's definitely,
we definitely get some funny
situations where the, the,
the seal that's,
you know,
Super Macho and we're over working with
some in some foreign country and some
guys, you know, they,
they're talking to them,
they start to like him or wherever
they started getting along.
We're going to start holding the hands on.
I'll walk over to the galley.
He see she see a TV as leg and nod out.
Somebody needs to brief
you on our customs.
We don't do that well according to
the book. That's what I'm saying.
You got to, you know, just go
ahead and hold the advancements
in homeboy. But yeah,
that's the kind of thing that,
that is rough for Americans,
especially American dudes to get over.
We're just going to walk around
holding hands or like, you know how um,
in Europe they'll like
kiss not necessarily on the
lips necessarily. Right.
Butt Cheek, right? Yeah. He
tried to kiss me on the cheek.
Dud that make me weird for the day is
jam me weird for the day for me to do it.
If I send me random.
Yeah,
no kissing is no factor
in much of the world for,
for a guy to kiss another guy like,
hey good to see you plant one on me.
Here's an American. It's like, Hey, good
to see you. Keep out of my personal space.
Actually you don't have to be honest.
Um,
I don't care like people actually some
of my friends, they, you know, some,
you know like the Italian
mafia kind of thing.
Like they'll build it and we'll do that.
So my friends,
they kind of know what the f you know
what thing broke down my personal space
more than anything else. Yes I do. Yes.
She just uses the whole thing of like
hugging another dude when you see him.
I think that stemmed from Jujitsu.
Oh frill.
I don't remember ever
doing that before Jujitsu.
I have to think more,
but it just cause cause you did,
sue is so close anyways that when you,
you know,
you're just like that's the way it
is. Yeah. So do Jitsu once again,
spreading for the spreading
customs around the world,
breaking down boundaries,
breaking down boundaries.
They broke down boundaries
for me in Hawaii,
there's a lot of kissing that
goes on, mostly between, um,
like between slightly, you
know, like girls and guys,
like even like if it's like your
friend's wife, you kiss him on the cheek.
That's how like it's in fact if
you don't, it's kind of like, hmm.
That was kind of standoffish kind of
thing. Not a huge deal, but it's like,
it's that normal in Hawaii.
Um, but guys and guys,
you know, I don't, I don't
think that that's an issue.
Like if someone kissed me on my cheek
when they saw me and it was a guy,
I love you bro, whatever.
Like that wouldn't, that
wouldn't move me either way.
That'd be like, yeah, fine.
But I'm saying if you,
you did cause you would have like a
specific type of personality, you know,
they'd be like,
that's a new new thing for chocolate.
Guess that would be a new
exploration, I guess. Brother.
There was a time where I think we're doing
like a Facebook live or something and
we're talking about cauliflower
ear and um, and I was like oil.
So I said something about late
after your ears are like soft.
And then I went and you were right next
to me and I, and I like, like flipped
your ear or something.
And when I watched the live later,
the look on your face was like,
you were genuinely,
not in a big way but
genuinely slightly offended by
my ear.
Like it was micro was there.
I was at my Jujitsu Academy when I was
in Virginia Beach and there was a buddy
of mine,
another seal,
and I had gotten him into Jiu
Jitsu and he was a small guy,
like one 41 45 scenario and,
but you know,
he was like a white belt, had been
trained in and whatnot. And um,
we were both,
so now we were training and one night
I showed up at the academy and we both
showed up at the same time,
like similar time.
And in this academy it was Gustava
Machado and Guga as his nickname.
Great Dude.
And so we,
and Google is academy at the time was
pretty small and it had one bathroom and
the bathroom is where you would change.
So like put your d on or whatever.
So my buddy goes in there
and he starts changing.
And me being just like a team guy,
I'm like, whatever I'm going into. So,
and he's a lot smaller than me and I'm
a blue belt at this time. So you know,
there's, there's that
level of, of uh, you know,
like Keke he knows that the
situation unfolds. I can submit him.
That's the way it is. And so I just bust
into the bathroom and he's in there.
He's changing. So He's, you know, I
don't know if he was completely naked,
but he was pretty close. And I come in
and just drop my a rip off my shirt,
dropped my shorts and, and,
and, and I hear him go, oh,
and then he goes, and then he
goes, uh, think of a happy place.
We both started laughing, but, um, yeah,
don't care about any of that stuff.
So there you go,
try and try and accept other people's
customs and don't try and impose your
customs on them or you're not doing
good for the diplomacy of the country.
Yeah, yeah. Like, even
when you go to like France,
not to keep the customs
thing going too long,
but whether it be France or wherever.
Right.
Here's the,
it's a hard one.
So let's say you go to the beach where
they can go topless. They're at the beach,
right? What if you're with your wife
or whatever and your wife's like, oh,
we're in France. I want
to go topless. You know,
how do you feel about
that? Whatever. All good.
I don't think we're going
to a topless beach actually.
What she wanted to go though,
she doesn't answer the way I would see it.
We're so conservative.
Right? Isn't that crazy?
We're super conservative for it
to actually, puritans are legit.
Yeah. I like the puritans. It
meant that's the New England.
There's a little thread of puritanism
up in New England and I was like that.
Yeah, I can dig it. Um,
at a topless beach, I would let
totally let my wife go. Totally.
Except if there is anyone there
that we knew. Interesting.
So like if my brother's
friends or if my friend,
unless it was her girlfriends,
I wouldn't care. But yeah,
if it was any of our friends that we knew
there were guys that would bother me,
I think, well my wife just be,
she'd be wearing a swimsuit.
This is no real big discussion.
Right. The Edna, I did dig it.
Would you wear,
you know how they were like the more what,
like the trunks that are like speedo
type trunks. That's how you know it's a,
it's a speedo. Yeah. Yeah.
Yeah. Would that be all you are?
We need to stick with this. I
wear surf shorts. I probably,
you got books as in Brazil,
you know,
it's called a song gow yet. Hello?
Yeah. And Dean lister, this the,
Oh,
I'm good friends with dean. Sure. He went
through a phase of wearing a sung gow
yeah.
A lot to train him and like that at all
dudes basically wearing a speedo and
beating me up and not fun. Yeah. And he'd
go with no shirt for sure. So yeah. That,
that's um, yeah, where that
[inaudible] needs to do that for sure.
They used to be pretty common
for, it's definitely faded
right now. Yeah, for sure.
The idea of just wearing
the tidy whities song.
Gow grappling. Yeah, for
sure. For sure. Fully.
But on the beach though, you got to lay
up Brazil, Brazil. That's your normal.
That's, that's the custom, but not you.
You're not going to adopt that customer.
I'm American dude. I know Bro. But you,
when you go to these foreign lands to
America, you know, turn the box me.
I'm just saying the book said, I
didn't say the book said, you know,
and you're just, you're going to so
bay, that Brown, whatever you like.
Yeah. I'm going to stick to
this. Your dish. That's what
we do over here. Yes sir.
You done? Yes sir. Trying
to frame me up. Rumor,
rumor is the most primitive
way of spreading stories
by passing on from mouth to
mouth. It is just as inefficient,
inaccurate and unaccountable
as it is. Primitive.
Rumors are repeated by even by
those who do not believe the tails.
That's an interesting statement
and it's very true. This is this.
This is an interesting state.
When you look at it from the viewpoint
of fake news right now and Russian bots,
rumors are repeated by even those
who do not believe the tails.
There is a fascination about them.
The reason is that they cleverly designed
is that cleverly designed rumors give
expression to something deep in the
hearts of the victims, the fears,
suspicions,
forbidden hopes or daydreams,
which they hesitate to voice directly.
So if a commanding officer can keep
track of the rumors that are going around
among his men, he will learn a great
deal about their current fears and hopes.
He will have a sort of barometer that
registers the rises and falls of their
morale. That's a good point. People
are out. We're going to get attacked.
That means everyone's afraid that they're
going to get attacked or we're not
going to be, we're not going home on time,
okay? Everyone's concerned about that,
so pay attention to those rumors.
A rumor is not always a lie,
not always a malicious story,
and there are uses of rumor in war.
You can use it for disruption.
You can use it as a smokescreen. You can
use it for discrediting news sources.
This is a special technique and they
weren't doing that all the time.
Now there's different kinds of rumors.
There's the pipe dream rumor,
I thought pipe dream was a modern term.
There's the pipe dream rumor
which depends on wishful thinking.
There's pleasure and believing and
repeating what you hope is true.
The boogie man rumor is the opposite
of the pipe dream. It expresses fear,
not a wish.
The wedge driving rumor,
perhaps the most dangerous of all is the
rumor that attempts to create hostility
and distrust between allies or between
particular groups within a country.
So you have to watch out for that.
What makes rumor work,
and I think this is probably the
most important part of this section.
Rumors thrive on fertile soil.
What soil is fertile?
Lack of information about
important things, favor rumor,
rumors encouraged by discontent,
frustration, boredom and idleness.
Expectation fosters rumors.
Censorship since it blocks
important news favors rumor
and from those that you can get
to how to control rumor one,
ensure good faith in
official communications.
If the public loses confidence in the
reliability of the communications of the
armed forces and of the press and
radio than rumors began to spread fast.
So you've got to tell the truth to develop
faith in leaders. People can stand,
people can stand censorship and lack of
news when they feel they are sure that
they are not being told falsehoods and
that what is being held back is being
held back for good reason.
That applies to all leaders from
the president to the humble,
his school teacher from
the general to the corporal
three present as many facts as possible.
Let the press and radio give as full and
circumstantial news as they can without
giving too much aid to the enemy.
But the armed forces do the same.
Men want facts when they
can't get facts they take.
This is something that we all
the time in echelon front,
we'll go into a company and they're
having problems with the rumors and the
reason that they're having problems
with rumors is cause the the people.
The leadership is not explaining
what is happening. So there's,
for whatever reason, they decide they're
going to close down a location. You know,
maybe it's because the rent was too high
and they're gonna look for a different
space.
Maybe it's because the market had
dropped down there so much that it was a,
it was losing money. But what's the rumor
when if you don't tell people about,
the rumors were called out of business,
so they already shut down
Pleasanton and whatever the,
we're going down find a new job.
So when you don't explain to
people what's going on, it's good.
I just had a, a guy, uh,
leader who had to get rid of somebody
and then a turned into a big email
craziness where the guy that got fired
sent his closing email to everyone.
I'm going to miss you guys.
I'm sorry that it didn't work out.
I hope this doesn't bode bad for
everyone else. Like one of those, right?
Mass email. So, and the guy going, what?
What do you think I should do? I mean,
this is, I shouldn't have
to like respond. And I said,
you don't have to respond,
but if you don't respond,
these people are going to create. They're
going to run with everything he said.
So craft an email and say,
hey everyone,
sorry to see Billy. Go
Billy. We wish you luck.
Or maybe you don't include Billy on the
email. In fact, it probably wouldn't,
but sorry to see Billy go,
here's what happened.
Here's what unfolded here
was our financial situation.
We were actually losing money in
his division. Uh, not for one month,
not for three months,
but for 14 straight months.
I had asked him repeatedly to conduct
or to make these changes and he hadn't
made any changes.
And although I like Billy as a person,
I couldn't sacrifice everyone
at this company. For one person,
what we need is to be profitable.
And with Billy in charge of that division,
we're losing money.
And as the leader,
I can't allow my loyalty to one person
to Trump my loyalty to everyone here.
Therefore I had to let him go.
Now we've gotten that room under control.
Next keep men and women busy.
Was it?
What's funny is that leader
was telling me this, you,
I never had to do this before. Tell
everyone an email. What's going on? Oh,
you never had an email,
right? Email's relatively new,
you know, and so it's not like
somebody was sending out a mass email,
throwing darts at spears,
that everyone's from the,
from their email for keep men and women
busy prevent idleness and Ma Monotony.
Empty minds are easily filled
with untruths and worries.
Idle hands make busy tongues fight
rumor mongering campaign against rumor,
expose it as enemy propaganda.
Discredit specific rumors as inaccurate
and false caricature rumormongers.
And this section is called psychological
warfare. Interestingly enough,
death can be inflicted upon the bondy's
of an enemy destruction upon property.
But defeat is a conquest of the mind.
In total war,
economic,
military and psychological action are
all used to bring about submission in the
enemy. Economic Action deprives
the enemy of vital materials.
Military action destroys his
armies by killing, capturing,
scattering the soldier smashing or
capturing the guns, tanks, planes, trucks,
and supplies.
But it is successful psychological action
that in the end it deprives the enemy
of his will to resist and can spoil the
individual soldier as a fighting machine
by removing the one thing that
makes him fight the hope of success.
The soldier without hope
is like a tank without gas.
When you come right down to it.
All warfare,
military and economic to
is psychological warfare.
Since willingness to
surrender is a state of mind,
all these different means are used to
bring about a change of mind to convert
determination to resist into
willingness to accept defeat.
The chief tool of psychological warfare,
the one that is most peculiar,
particularly psychological,
is propaganda.
Since propaganda tries to change opinion,
the people who plan propaganda have to
know all about the opinions of those.
They are trying to change.
You can't be intelligent about changing
anything unless you know what it is
you're trying to change.
Good point,
and then it talks about how you
figure out what people's opinions are.
You have to gather that information
and how to pull for that information.
Then it talks about a
little bit about propaganda.
The truth is the best
propaganda propaganda does
not have to be dishonest or
lying.
Hitler said that a lie will be believed
if it is big enough and it may be at
first,
but the big lies don't stand up.
Eventually the truth catches
them and unmasks them.
The goal of propaganda is always
a change in the state of mind.
Good propaganda always starts from a fact,
okay?
There is a formula for victory
in psychological warfare.
One the enemy must be weary.
He must be sick and tired and discouraged
to the second step in psychological
warfare is to turn
disillusionment into despair.
To convince the weary enemy
that victory is impossible.
The third step is to
promise something better.
Show him a way out the corner to beast,
to fights to the death unless
he sees a way of escape
for after the creation of despair,
after the promise of something better,
there is left there is left still one
further step for psychological warfare.
The enemy must be led to fix
the blame on his own leaders.
The soldier who surrenders when he could
have fought on must have some excuse
and he will find it if his discipline is
broken down by his conviction that his
own leaders are responsible
for is unnecessary predicament.
That last step may come of itself,
but propaganda can help it.
So those are some really important
steps and if you think about them,
if you think about them from a
leadership perspective, they're very,
very powerful. If you think
about them from a business
perspective, they are very,
very powerful.
And when you know the offense,
you also have to understand the
defense against psychological warfare.
Number one,
don't trust the enemy.
Remember that broadcasts and leaflets
don't necessarily come from the sources
from which they claim to come from. And
by the way, that also applies to emails,
articles, tweets, social media posts.
Russian bots
be critical.
Even though a story starts off
with what you know to be true,
don't trust the interpretation
that is tacked onto the truth.
And so don't accept first interpretation.
You hear about the reason the battle is
won or lost or the reason there isn't
any more coffee.
Wait,
the first story is the best propaganda
because it has no other story to overcome
but it is not necessarily
the best for you to believe.
But in general
don't trust the enemy.
Don't trust the enemy.
If he turns friendly,
fear him or better understand that he's
up to no good. If you are captured,
tell them just your name,
rank and serial number and nothing else
just because he seems friendly and well
meaning don't spill things
you think are unimportant.
It wraps up with this trust only
your own leaders there for you.
Trust them
and be wise
and that's kind of an interesting way
to to to finish up that book is that
statement.
Trust them but be wise.
Trust you leaders but but at the same
time be wise and you've got to pay
attention to that because it's
a little counter to trust,
right? It's saying trust but be wise
and I and I actually agree with that
question. Everything be wise
question, everything question.
Your leaders don't follow people blindly.
You can put your trust in them. Sure.
But at the same time you have to be wise.
Be Wise to question them,
be wise to try and
understand their decisions,
be wise enough to disobey them.
Should they choose to lead in a manner
that is detrimental to the mission,
to the strategic objectives
and to common sense. Okay.
And you know what,
you got to be wise not just about
your leaders but about everyone.
Seek to understand.
Okay.
Seek to understand people which you do
by watching them and by observing
them and by listening to them.
And you know one thing that we do people
do is we spend a lot of time on output.
Yeah.
We are sending all the time,
we are talking all the time.
We are putting information
out all the time.
Learn to be on receive mode a little bit
more. Learn to listen a little bit more.
Learn to capture and absorb and
utilize a what other people reveal.
And when you do that you'll garner
a better understanding of them,
of yourself, of your team, of your enemy,
the nature of the battle itself and
the nature of humans themselves.
So listen and learn and understand
so that you can become wise.
Because if you become wise,
then you can win.
And that wraps up this incredible book,
psychology for the fighting man,
what you should know
about yourself and others.
All right, so echo, I know, um,
you've got some hopefully some information
to tell us how to become a little bit
wiser in our movement down the path
that our movement towards winning in all
aspects of life in this total war that
we are fighting on a daily basis in all
directions. Yes sir. I do.
We got,
okay.
Do you do to is one of the many ways and
now what kind of gear are we going to
get when we
do Jujitsu, foraging and
g? That's the answer.
Did people have not been asking me that
recently? That's good. That's good.
Well, hopefully it's good.
Hopefully that signifies
that. They already know. They know. Yeah.
Hopefully it doesn't signify
that people are slowing down.
Starting to do actually,
which you know what?
I know from different input that
I'm receiving because I'm out.
Resigned on receiving Loredo
good that people are starting.
Did you still just finished my first
Jujitsu class got rolled out? Yeah.
Just finished my Jujitsu class.
I'm just finished my first stripe
on that white belt. Oh yeah.
So people are getting on the
path for sure. Yeah. And Stain,
cause I'm hearing about blue belts.
No. Yeah. And we're in that mode.
We've been in that mode for for like
maybe a year almost where it goes.
People are starting to get blue
belt started to see blue belts. He
merged stripes are sure
you are the pro, the, yeah.
We're seeing blue belts were three years.
A little over three years
deep in the podcast.
We should have our first
hopefully potential Jocko podcast.
Blackbelt within seven years
is my prediction. Yeah. Yeah.
Right. Yeah. I would say average
10 years. How long did it take?
Maybe it took a few months before
people started going, okay,
I'm going to start this Jujitsu stuff
cause he's guys won't stop talking about
it. But I was going at
wrestling tournaments. This is,
this was awesome.
Going to wrestling tournaments and having
kids that are freshmen in high school.
So there are 1314 years old.
Guess what started in grappling?
A little jar called wait,
no little book called way of the warrior.
The warrior kid got them on the path and
so now they started that when they were
11 years old, two, three years ago
and they read way of the warrior kid.
I want to learn how to wrestle and
then the kids come up to me. Hey Sir,
are you all good?
My name's Freddy and I started
wrestling because I got into Jujitsu,
so thank you.
So that's one of the best thing that's
happened to me in a long time because why?
Because I know that that kid is going
to have like legitimately better life
because they know how to do Jujitsu
and wrestle. Their life will be better.
So if you're doing Jujitsu,
you get an origin.
He getting origin g made in America and
designed specifically for [inaudible]?
No, for judo, no for hop. Kido? Nope.
Designed for one thing. Brazilian
Jujitsu. That's what it's made for. And
by black belt by,
by Jujitsu.
Black belt people made it.
That's legit.
Also got some other clothes up
there. T shirts, sweatshirts.
We'll working on boots.
I can't talk about that yet because
then people will be on me for the next
whatever as we try and get we can do,
we have the machinery in place,
we've got models being built.
I have a pair,
I know you don't have a
pair cause you're not quite,
you know on the inner inner circle.
Yeah.
You look really despondent when I
said that. That's okay. I broke,
I broke his arm anyway.
Oh kiss for you later.
You get all these things at origin,
main.com.
Other stuff on there like supplements,
most important supplements.
I'd lift weights, whatever.
And I've always had probably
like maybe 15 years I would say.
Always said like this elbow,
like I wouldn't call it tendonitis,
although I have had tendonitis
in my elbow. So can you
just an elbow thing? Yeah.
And so when I first got in joint warfare
and the oil go egg Gwyn away complete
right. Went away completely. So recently
I got like heavy back into limb.
Like man I can, you can go right.
So it sort of starts to come back.
But now it's like at this
phase where all feet,
like right now if I tried to do like
a close grip pushup or something like,
like right now in this
cold room I'll feel it,
but the amount of sets that I have to do
to warm it up or now reduced to one one
usually it was every single set of more,
it was like three,
four sets of warmup that my first set
I could feel it but I could get over.
It was like that. So it's like, and I'm
getting older, I'm not getting younger.
I know it seems obvious, but given
the way my elbow feels, you know,
not that obvious.
Reviews on people for
joint warfare are awesome.
People are,
they get that where something has been
bothering them for so long and they get
on the joint warfare for all on
the Krill oil and you feel good.
That's what makes it,
in my opinion,
the most important supplement or we
kind of something allows you to work
harder. So true. So yeah, joint warfare,
boom, get down one super krill oil,
some added antioxidants in there.
And then discipline, which is,
it's a combination of two things.
It's a little physical energy boost and
a mental cognitive increasing capacity
to think you.
So that's discipline.
The drink discipline go is that,
but it's in the form of a pill.
So or wait,
they call it a capsule
capsule. Yeah, it's a capsule.
I told Brian at orange little,
hey man,
discipline. I'm addicted to the
drink, which I love it. Thank you.
Um, for, for helping me
get this to the world.
However, if I'm going to go up
on stage and talk for two hours,
I can't pound two bottles of discipline.
You know why?
It's a real simple reason.
It is what it is.
It's a biological reason.
Yeah.
Drink two liters of water and you're
going to have to go to the bathroom.
Yes sir. I don't want to have
to stop. Hey, hold on a minute.
Crowd of 700 people. I'm just going
to go hit the head real quick.
That's not happened yet.
So took the discipline formula.
We made it into a capsule.
Now I can just pop three
discipline when I'm going to need,
when are we going to need that
little edge to edge? You don't,
as Jason Gardner put it to me,
the word searching gets reduced to zero
like you don't word search anymore in
your head. You know when you're saying
stuff that still is there. Okay.
Then there's that energy
drink, one version, right?
The energy drink is coming is not out yet.
Well,
the video with JP, yes.
Origin, boom. Yeah.
Clearly the energy drink is made.
It is made,
but it's not in production yet,
and I'm going to go into why. Well,
the reason why it's not in production is
because of the way we are producing it,
which is a way that no one else is doing
because the bottom line is there's all
kinds of, what'd you call it? Energy.
There's all kinds of energy
drinks out there right now, right?
They're not good for you.
The closest thing you can get to an energy
drink that's good for you is actually
Jocko white tea. That's the closest
thing you can get because it tastes good.
It's got some caffeine.
Some antioxidants,
we're taking that to the next
level with the discipline,
go ready to drink in a can.
It tastes delicious and
it's actually good for you.
This is the difference.
So that'll be out,
I'm guessing we're probably not
looking for another two months,
so no reason to get all excited yet. I'll
let you know when it was all out there.
In the meantime,
the discipline powder is
a good variant for now.
But yeah, the discipline going to
Cannes, it's really, it's nailed.
It nailed it for samples.
They're gone. I mean,
I'm down,
I don't drink energy drinks,
but if there's like one there that
like I know it's going to taste good.
I'm Kinda, I'm Kinda, I like those, you
know? So that one was like, ah. Yeah.
And that's the thing is that it
tastes good, which is awesome.
It's actually good for you. You
know, there's no, it's just so
good to go.
Also got milk and you wanna get on the
milk train for some additional protein in
addition to your Ribeye steaks.
And here's the thing,
in addition to your Tomahawk Ribeye
steak. Well yeah, he did the thing,
you need additional protein if you're
working out. Do you do that straight up?
Otherwise your buddy, what eats
itself and you want that to happen.
And I'll tell you what, even if you don't
need additional protein, you know what?
You need dessert.
Yeah.
So luckily milk is its own.
Why?
What is more?
What does this mean?
It means really tasty nectar that is going
to make you stronger and you can have
it for dessert.
When you get done having dessert,
you won't get done with it and think,
oh, I still want some ice cream. No,
you'd be like, I'm done with it and I'm
done and I'm feeling great. We're good.
Okay.
So I made this,
here's a new little dish in my little,
I dunno, whatever. Yeah.
So I go egg white omelet with like,
I'll take like leftovers can omelet.
No.
So you know, for example, my wife made
pot roast, right? So it's like pot roast.
There's little carrots in there. You
know, there's potatoes in there. Yes.
So I'll take some leftover pot roast
and I'll make an egg white omelette with
the pot roast, right? It seems kind of
what I, but whatever the leftovers is,
most part, I'll make an Omelette with
it. And so I made it and it's good.
That's like good nutrients right there.
That's a solid like post workout,
whatever tastes good too. And then
you know, no sugar, no, you know,
it's like legit and tastes really good.
So I pound, that was not last night.
The night before look pound
that. I'm like, man, I'm so,
not only did I get a good,
healthy,
delicious little meal that I made,
I'm like,
you know how you have say pain in the
mood for some dessert and in a way,
in a weak mind, in a matter
of speaking, in a week, man,
you can be like, hey, I had such a
healthy dinner. I can kind of, you know,
exercise some freedom on
the dessert little bit.
But I mixed up the milk.
Double Win when bone stayed on the
discipline path and when your foot,
when you're kind of full like that.
Sometimes you eat a giant steak but you're
still, even though you're pretty full,
you want to have a little dessert.
Yeah. Little one. Scoop hitter. Yeah,
my middle one scoop hitter scoops and
lately I will say I've been mixing less
milk and more Malke.
Okay. Yes. It's thicker,
like oily and it's so good. It's like
a little, it's a straight up milkshake.
Get that hit her as my brother feel.
Von would say true.
Also warrior kid milk.
That's for the kids and think it's for
kids until you try that strawberry that
too, but that's a good on this
sweat. Strawberry chocolate. Is it?
That's the only two right
now. Right now. Yeah. Yeah,
and then the strawberry that's going
to go to the regular pretty soon it's
coming. We're working on it.
He's also, Jack was a store.
You going to stay on the path.
Good. Of course stay on the path,
but if you want to represent
while you're on the path,
we've got some shirts for you.
If you want discipline equals freedom,
it's a good one. He gets two versions
of that by the way. All the new ones,
you know. Yes. And
they're both in the game.
Fully good ways to represent some hoodies
on. They're also more rash guards.
So you want to represent and people
have been representing tournaments,
competitions with get after it, you know,
on the rash guard. These are all, yeah,
so really good. Yet when you see
people straight representing Oh yeah.
In the competition, big time.
Um, a lot of cool. So again,
hats,
flex, fit hat, uh, you know, I think
we might discontinue the trucker hats,
but I see what it,
that w we have chapters has
zero credit for selling that,
that was so bad. Well, we have
both truckers had and flex.
It had also hoodies. Oh eight already
said he's anyway, gone there. Jocko,
store.com.
If he likes something,
get something represent and support.
It's true.
It's also yourself, Jocko white
tea. Okay. Any it can, yes. Okay.
Okay.
Little bit of caffeine in there.
Antioxidants deadlift 8,000 pounds.
That's good. It's good. Like my wife
Dead Lifts 8,000 Times, you know?
Um, more of a mild taste compared
to the energy drink at night.
I know you mean energy drink in
general. No. Your, your [inaudible].
She would not call that an
energy drink. I wouldn't, yeah,
I would call it something. I
would call it discipline. Go.
Yeah, I dunno. I think, yeah.
Well the jury is still out it now
cause it's kind of an energy drink.
The problem is energy. You don't
want the not good for you. Yeah.
You don't want the stigma. Energy
are literally bad for you. Yeah.
We'll think about talent nonetheless.
Jocko white tea, not an energy drink.
It's actual t sort of
a certified organic u.
S d a no,
certified organic. So yeah, you can get
that one in a can or what do you call it?
Loose? No, that's not loose leaf. Dry in
the bags or whatever. That's a good one.
You also subscribe to the podcast.
If you don't subscribe to the podcast,
then echo's going to keep telling you.
If I don't tell you as quickly as
possible to subscribe to the podcast to do
that.
And don't forget about the warrior kid
podcast because your kids need to be
shown the path.
And I hate to say this,
not by you. Well know. In
addition to you telling them,
in addition to you
trying to convince them,
because if you remember
when you were a kid,
you didn't want to listen to your dad.
You didn't want to listen to your mom.
You kind of always thought, well,
he may be just, I might look,
I might only be 11 years old,
but I think I know a little bit
better than my dad for sure.
You think very least he don't understand.
He's still the Jake can talk to your kid,
get him on the path,
let them know what's up.
And also you get the warrior kids
soap at the Irish oaks ranch. Dot.
Calm Young Aden,
young aid making soap,
having his own business, buying
the material, growing the material.
Get some of that so that you
can stay clean. You got Youtube.
Subscribe to the Youtube Channel so
that you can see echoes, legit videos.
Technically you don't have to subscribe.
I'll just check it out then. But yeah,
if you want subscribed,
that's a good one.
Subscribe like and comment
anyway like it shoot for,
for those that don't know, we do
have a youtube channel. If you,
if you're interested in the video
version of Charles, looks like. Yeah.
If you want us to comment that Echo looks
jacked or is Jack there is yoked. Sure.
Then you can do that there.
Don't forget about psychological warfare.
It's an album to help you get through
moments of weakness by hearing pragmatic
information about why you should stay on
the path that is it. Itunes, Google play,
MP, three platforms. It's true.
Also your home gym when you're expanding,
cause we're always expanding.
I know I'm expanding your stuff.
Go to on it and so on at.com/jocko.
Good spot.
Good equipment of all kinds for Jim.
Also information on there. So yeah,
when you get into kettle bells,
cause you gotta do kettlebells.
Kettlebells are good. Yes.
So you want some info on their bulletin.
That's where he can get a lot of good
stuff on there going on at.com/jocko I
wrote a bunch of books.
If you want to get the books,
go to Jocko podcast.com and
then click on the various books.
Mikey and the dragon is a book
that I wrote. It's for little kids,
but everyone gets something out of it
and it's a cool story that rhymes you and
it's delivered very eloquently.
If, I don't know if eloquent,
the word eloquent is even compatible with,
with you as as a whole concept
or whatever, but I will,
I'll use it.
Very eloquent check.
So Mike and the dragons for kids also for
kids way the warrior kid and weigh the
warrior kid too, which is called
Mark's mission and also waive the war,
your kid three which is
called where there's a whale
and that book is coming out
in the spring.
Get your kid these books because they
will point them in the right direction on
so many things.
I wish I had these books when I was a
kid so badly and I hope that the kids,
you know, read these books and get
themselves on the path and if an adult,
you know,
needs to get on the path,
give them the discipline
equals freedom field manual,
which tells people how to get after it.
Everybody needs to know how to
get after it. In my opinion.
It's a good little daily read.
It's not a normal book.
It's different. Yes, very
different. So check that one out.
And then of course there
is extreme ownership.
The first book that I wrote
with my brother Leif Babin
and also we just released
last year dichotomy of leadership and
I'm starting to think there's people
starting to comment that dichotomy of
leadership is now starting to emerge
from the shadow of his older brother.
And we're starting to think that dichotomy
of leadership is going to be a little
bit more yoked, little bit
more jacked. And may you serp,
the older brother may end up being
the one that people really dial into.
So check them out.
Also speaking of books,
if you want this book,
psychology for the fighting man or
any of the books that Jocko covers,
got them on a page on Jocko, podcast.com
on the top books from episodes.
That's what it says on the top
menu books from an episodes. Boom.
I got 'em by episode. Boom,
available right there. Get them.
If you want to know my reading, my
reading list, I recommended reading list.
That's my recommended reading list.
That's it.
It's Jocko podcast.com go to the little
tab that says books from the episodes.
Sure. Yeah, and then you can get them,
so that's that. That's a bunch of books.
Books that I've written,
other books that you can be educated by.
Books that have educated me.
Echelon Front leadership consultancy.
We solve problems through leadership.
That's what we do.
Me Wave Fab and JP Denelle,
Dave Burke, Flint Cochran,
Mike's Really Mike [inaudible]
and we are@echelonfront.com
also, we have the monster coming
up 2019 may 23 and 24 in Chicago,
September 19 to 20 and Denver,
December 4th and fifth and Sydney
go to extreme ownership.com to register.
Every event that we
have done has sold out.
These are absolutely going to sell it too.
And I thought,
I just talked to our ops director Jamie,
and she's like the hour we're ahead on
sales. And I was like, cool, it's glad,
I'm glad we got so many more seats.
And she's like, what? And I go,
well don't we have, don't we
have, you know, 1200 seats
or something? She's like, no.
The biggest we could get,
it's like,
it's still basically the
same size as San Francisco,
seven 50 or something like that.
So it's gonna sell out very quickly.
So if you want to come, please just
go and get on it. The F online,
online interactive training,
leadership training that
we did this because echelon front
is not big enough and cannot grow quickly
enough to train everyone that requests
training.
So what we did to scale what we do is put
it what we do into an online platform,
interactive,
very engaging.
It's what we do with companies and now
we can do it through the computer screen,
so e f online,
go and check that out
and finally f Overwatch's where we take
proven leaders from the battlefield,
from special operations and combat
aviation and we embed them into companies
where they can then help
that company lead and win.
That's an f overwatch.com if you're a one
of those veterans looking for a follow
on career or you're one of those companies
that needs people that understand the
mindset that we talk about in
the books and on this podcast,
go to f overwatch.com
and thank you for listening and if you
haven't had enough of us in three hours
straight and you want to communicate
with us some more, that's fine.
We are available on the
Inter webs on Twitter,
on Instagram
and on FAC.
Echo is an echo.
Charles and I am at Jocko Willink and
of course thanks to all our military
personnel for standing
watch around the world.
You protect our freedom
and we are indebted to you.
We are also indebted to our police
and law enforcement, firefighters,
paramedics and EMT correctional officer's
border patrol, all first responders.
You keep us safe and we thank you for
your service and sacrifice as well.
And to everyone out there listening,
remember how many lessons this book gives
about the way we think about the way
we act, about the way we follow in
about the way we lead it. And remember
that a good leader doesn't handle his man.
A good leader handles himself.
That's some of the best advice for
leadership and life I've heard in a long
time. So follow it. Handle
yourself. Keep yourself in check.
Keep yourself on the path.
Lead yourself so that you okay.
Become a person that others will follow
and they will follow you on that path.
The path of discipline,
the path of righteousness,
and the path that leads
to peace and freedom.
So until next time,
this is echo and Jocko out.